ah
a
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on hopefully
you can hear us and everything like that
because we've been moving all the [__]
around here so you know yeah let's just
do an audio check if audio sounds good
go ahead and drop it in the comments I
mean it says it's on yeah but it
sometimes gets turned off and
the camera gets moved around and yeah
[__] like that sorry about that Dad what
the hell
what are you doing out there
being bread next yeah what's up murder
Hornet who's an edge Lord
hi Zach hi Sebastian hi everybody yep so
it's another Friday night thank God and
yeah this has been a long week yeah
we're winding down we're not going
anywhere we're gonna stay in tonight
yeah I'm kind of I like going out I do
but um tonight I was just kind of like
man it'll just be nice to have a drink
and do the live stream and not go
anyplace eat some peanut butter cookies
Tommy peanut butter peanut butter
cookies they're pretty good they are
pretty good I wasn't really happy with
them when they came out of the oven when
they were still hot they were like it's
kind of mediocre when they cooled off
they tasted a lot better their tasted I
thought they were yummy but you know
what I mean you can't go wrong with
peanut butter yeah peanut butter cookies
evidently I haven't had one when they
were hot in a long time I guess they're
not that good when they're hot I kind of
feel like peanut butter cookies are one
of the few cookies that are actually a
little bit better when they're room
temperature yeah when they're in room
temperature I'm not really sure why that
is you can't really taste like the full
body of the peanut butter flavor when
there's super hot it's not like a
chocolate chip cookie where you got to
get that [__] rid of the oven oh yeah
right out of the oven those are good
actually oatmeal cookies right out of
the oven oatmeal cookies are ready
though yeah he made oatmeal cookies last
week I think well the peanut butter
cookies you made those you made some the
other night but you burned them yep
whatever
I uh thanks for reminding me Jen
but you know what one sheet pan bird in
this too and I still and I still uh did
the because
the first one
I went to go look for cooking time
and my eyes actually fell on prep time
said 15 minutes
the cook time was actually 10.
yeah overcooked them by five minutes in
our cookies that's [__]
critical yeah and I'm looking at this
recipe and it's saying 375.
Fahrenheit
I'm going I'm going I've never heard of
a cookie being cooked at 375 it's always
350.
yeah generally right so
they got they got me the wrong cooking
time too wrong cooking temperature and
the wrong cooking time normally a cookie
is about
10 minutes
yeah well that's what's this one 10
minutes and it's [__] 350.
it's not 375.
and I don't remember I go back and look
at anyway
the top rack
or the near I put had two racks in there
I had the two cookie sheets on the top
rack they cooked well at that
temperature in time but the one right
into the [__] cookie right in the
cookie sheet right underneath it in the
rack right underneath it burnt in the
same amount of time yeah
yeah it was only uh
thing is though it was only seven
cookies
oh okay so yeah I didn't know how many
it was a small one no all I know was you
were like oh I'm making peanut butter
cookies and then like a little while
later you yelled up the stairs I burned
up the first time yeah yeah first time
they all burned yeah the second time
only the ones on the bottom bird oh but
they look good on top yeah
black oh okay and it was like [__] but
there's only seven cookies in that sheet
well that's all right but I mean it
looked like you made a lot yeah I'll
make some more you made it I'll make
some more the problem but what I'm
saying is that you know that the
temperature's going to be too high 375
can't be yeah 350. I mean now that I
think about it not like I've made
millions of cookies but I've made a lot
of cookies in my day and usually yeah
350. yo y'all do me a favor Google
cooking time on [__] peanut butter
cookies
and temperature
it should be more like 10 minutes 350.
almost all cookies are 10 minutes unless
they're like yeah
and really you want them to be if you
want them if I like them a little less
than that like eight minutes so they're
a little bit
like soft a little soft yeah
and it should be I'm thinking 350 10
minutes
that's got me that they had me 375 10
minutes it worked
but not on that bottom rack yeah
interesting
and there's oatmeal ones you made before
were really good too yeah those are 350.
those are like last week and yeah and we
had to like compromise on it because Tom
likes reasons and his oatmeal cookies
and I am not a fan I'm like I like I
want nuts in my oatmeal cookies
it was pecans and they came out really
good yeah they came out really good
actually it was pecans it was wild
excuse me it was walnuts and uh crushed
walnuts and raisins yeah they they did
come out good I didn't know I just got
raisins I got to get rid of yeah gotta
use them
and I got a bunch of Craisins too
cranberry I like those I got a bunch of
those like those are actually really
good at oatmeal cookies
uh High Desert zero zero four says by
the way love your Lovecraft necklace
thank you very much I always get a lot
of compliments on this I got this from
like years ago like a friend of mine got
it from Etsy and gave it to me for my
birthday like many many years ago
probably 10 years ago I don't know maybe
not that long but a long time ago
um yeah Zach says I've had the strangest
week so far hung out with a sort of X
which was fun got real worried worried
about him got back in touch with another
friend worked on a Power Rangers Fan
Film for our friend editing is saying
forever and my dad got furloughed from
his job after only being back for a week
so yay that's great
great
slasher Fred said uh do you remember
those Mother's Cookies were they the
ones that were like the soft yeah they
eat like remember remember like Keebler
had those soft batch ones yeah I
remember those I think like after soft
cookies started getting real popular I
remember those the just the name is
ringing a bell
it was 80s I think I kind of remember
what the package looked like yeah it
seems to me
that I saw a video about like that
mentioned them not too long ago because
I watch a lot of those weird history
food videos and stuff like that so maybe
it was on there
kalon Higgins said I don't mind cookies
being a little burnt at the bottom
depends on what kind of cookie it is
because I kind of like ones that are
sort of like crispy on the edges and
like kind of gooey in the middle way the
bottom rack on this one did this today
it looked like a totally blonde cookie
on a top like fine flip it over it's
totally black the cookies isn't even
thick see that's yeah they were like
they're pretty thin that's like uh weird
that's some uneven yeah some even
cooking [__] that's an electric oven
action yeah [__] hate electric pull
that [__] out if I can put a gas bottle
a propane gas bottle next to it in the
cupboard
it'd be a good idea huh get a gas stove
yeah because he's always complaining
about [__] hate it and then I'll get
the propane bottles from the grill and
bring them in and put them in the
cabinet next to the [__] that we
don't have to run it out running it all
around the house
I have the gas outside
I mean I could do that but I'd rather
have it clandestinely inside just run it
just put the program blow the house up
if it kills them yeah
hey you know that's a that's like a raw
solution
let me get a gas oven
give me that bottle
he's gonna he's gonna [__] yeah
that's just it's almost that's almost on
the same level as like all the people
that have been um you know like deep
frying their turkeys for Thanksgiving
and like blowing [__] up you know what I
mean yeah so it's gonna be like that I
do that too well I could do that yeah I
got a big old pot
I just don't have the propane
um burner yeah those aren't expensive
though
you probably get it for 50 bucks
I don't know I don't know if I if it
would be good enough to be worth the
effort I mean I I really just like
turkey in the oven to be honest with you
it's good deep fried
yeah I know but I'm just saying a lot of
stuff's good and you also need
everything I mean pretty much everything
is good deep fried that's sort of yeah
that helps with crawfish boil too if you
got a whole bunch of crawfish
Zach says I'm into boring granny snacks
I love my pecan sandies I love those too
actually I don't even care if they're
grainy cookies but they're those [__]
that's shit's delicious yeah they're
like shortbread you know yeah
they were actually when we go to um
Ichiban yeah the you know the buffet
Chinese buffet sometimes they have uh on
the dessert bar they have like almond
cookies Chinese like and those are
really good because they're not like
super sweet so like sometimes yeah so
and it's almost exactly like a pecan
candy except not quite as thick yeah but
it's almonds obviously other than pecan
so it's slightly different but those are
like really good so I usually have one
of those and then like some fruit I tear
Ichiban up man I punish them they're
gonna put shrimp out I'm gonna [__] them
up well that's what he's eating so you
should have never put these out he's
like rampaging through like eating all
the food
at all of the all that full soup bowls
that [__] cocktail sauce
and um then I'll eat the uh uh chicken
thigh on a stick and uh they got real
good pot stickers or dumplings fried
dumplings they're really good their
dumplings are really good they're almost
like they're handmade I think they might
be they're really good yeah that's one
thing because they have mostly the same
stuff as koiwan has but that was one
thing we did notice one there one they
have egg foo young which is which I
really like and they don't have that um
but also Ichiban their um dumplings are
better I think koi won I think those
come Frozen yeah and they just like
reheat them but the ones that Ichiban
look like they're um they're big look
like they're handmade they look like
they're handmade it tastes like they're
handmade people tear through them too
because it's like they're always running
out like I got up there the other day
there was one left and I had to like
scrape it out the back and then like
they just brought in a new pie the rest
of their stuff is mediocre
they're like the the General Tso's
chicken mediocre uh I don't usually eat
them yeah I had a couple bites of it the
honey chicken was okay uh they didn't
have any any of the deep fried chickens
with the sauces on it they're just okay
oh they're not bad they're just you know
koi wants better but there are other
shits
better actually I think I think the
shrimp is about a little bit better
because there's more of it outed at one
time yeah
and well it's hard to [__] up shrimp
hard to [__] up boiled shrimp
um
but uh you know the other stuff's good
and I like the ice cream bar better
and the desserts
yeah they do have better desserts yeah
like more they have more of them and
more of a variety I don't get that many
but the clientele man is uh
a lot more redneck
well it's the part of town that is big
people Nothing But whole families of fat
people
like the [__] most gorgeous
[__]
economy sir and her man
yeah yeah thank you thank you I don't
know where the [__] these people are
from you know we're like the only people
on Florida our only only people under
300 pounds
I mean yeah easily easily there's I got
250 300 Pounders in there 400 pounds
look like something yeah [__] huge
and then Chinese weight staff running
around [__] playing grab ass and [__]
it was funny they had a cute Chinese
woman in there with some Chinese guy and
he's flirting with her and he's he's
getting action they're hiding behind the
bar and I can see what's going they're
probably in their 30s but I said he's
after her and the [__] I was just
talking about what JJ was laughing
they were super cute
they were like they were super in love
face she looked like one of those
statues out of that damn Chinese too
you know those little [__] soldiers
faces she had like a face like that
she's probably about five eight
and um she had a booty otter man I
couldn't believe it she'd have a nice
bus yeah and he was chasing it he was
chasing not a big butt but a nice yeah a
nicely form it was like an apple
yeah yeah she had see this is the kind
of [__] that we talk about
she had a banging figure the [__]
Chinese guy yeah he was into it yeah
they were they were super cute they were
trying to like I I'm trying to keep it
on download they were trying to keep
another download but it was like pretty
obvious that they're just like yeah yeah
it was like pretty funny I was like oh
they're adorable
but you know what I mean uh Sebastian
says Tom and Jenny I got the Mammoth
Mountain Poltergeist book looking
forward to reading it oh awesome that's
awesome oh yeah I hope you like it if
you don't want us to autograph it just
send it to us we'll autograph it send it
back yeah I mean it'll take a while but
you know yeah uh High Desert says I miss
those iced oatmeal cookies they used to
be cheap like a bucket packages oh I
remember those damn Rock bought us
ghetto cookies they were good they were
good though they were good you put them
in milk and that's the thing like I said
when I was younger yeah you know raises
in them no you could get ones with
raisins in them but we never got the
ones with raisins because everyone would
complain and they had gingerbread
versions from there same company yeah
that's right yeah but they had yeah so
we would always have those because like
I said I grew up kind of kind of uh
working class let's put it that way so
we always had like all those like really
cheap Dollar Store like kind of snacks
and get [__] two pounds of animal
crackers with the [__] white and the
pink icing on them yeah with the little
breeds little balls on the beads on them
you guys know what I'm talking about
that's a sugar daddy
of them thanks but I remember those
oatmeal ones with the icing on yeah like
you could eat a whole [__] stack of
those yeah I probably couldn't nowadays
but back then I did that was 70 [__]
crappy but they were good yeah
but I wonder if you like heated him up
if they'd have been all right probably
not another one I liked was just like
the ant just um there was another cookie
that uh
it was like an animal cracker but tasted
just like a McDonald's cookie remember
the McDonald's like cookies yeah
they don't have those anymore no they
don't have any more mcdonaldland cookies
that look like Grimace and the hamburger
and I don't think they have those
anymore there was like an animal cracker
that was that same yeah duh it was
really good
that's yeah kind of addicted addictive
they were yeah they were kind of have a
buttery flavor to them
if you ate one you just would sit there
and eat all eat the whole pack
and then Zach asked if we remembered
those little Debbies that um the
brownies that were kind of like Play-Doh
consistency they still got those yeah
they're I'll eat them if it like if it's
all there is but that's not my favorite
little dip we don't buy those we grew up
with Little Debbie
that's that's a southern thing
and uh
they cost more than they used to but
they're better
the
the oatmeal pies I think are a little
better than they use the oatmeal cream
pies a little bit better than it used to
be they have a new peanut butter cookie
or peanut but what's it no but it's not
peanut butter cookie is it yeah they
call it peanut butter cookie right yeah
or something something like that it's a
bad ass but they're like 500 calories
each pretty much like it's like a meal
two peanut butter cookies about that big
around so size of a [__] moon pie
yeah it's big with with peanut butter in
in between sandwiched in between the two
cookies it's almost kind of like a like
a soft Nutter butter cookie cookie
remember yeah it's dense yeah it's dense
and it's it's like a whole meal in
itself and you can't eat it but that's
really good
they got all the new seasonal cakes they
got birthday cake birthday cakes I'm
really into those birthday cakes
birthday cake comes in a little bar and
it's individually wrapped and it's got
little sprinkles on it
and you can unwrap one birthday cake and
throw it in a bowl and put vanilla ice
cream next to it and [__] nuts just
like you had a birthday
I mean yeah you could present it's your
birthday well the thing that I like
about the birthday cake ones because if
I'm gonna buy them I've been buying
those because one they do taste just
like birthday cake like a birthday cake
you know not it's not quite like a zebra
cake I like those too but it's a
slightly differently
well the thing about it is that zebra
cakes they come two to a package yeah so
it's kind of like if you open a package
you kind of have to eat them both or
it's gonna go stale right so it's like
I'm like man that's like so many
calories though the nice thing about the
birthday cake one is it's small it's
just like in a bar and it's individually
wrapped so you don't feel quite like
such a fat though like just eating one
because you don't have to eat like both
of them yeah and it's like I really keep
them at the snack bar up here we got a
snack bar upstairs yeah under the ice
machine
every week or so we go and be like are
we gonna go get some small Debra's we'll
go get some small Debra's yeah I usually
get the birthday cake ones that's I got
two things of birthday cake ones last
time because those are really good
Dollar General sells out of them quickly
and they smell all the smaller boxes and
you know like a lot of times the the the
the the the the [__] ice cream or the
the sandwich itself is smaller too not
just the package you got to go to Publix
to get the the big the bigots and like
the expensive more designer flavors
Dollar General they just have the basic
one cream cream pie Swiss cake Swiss
cake roll sometimes Zebra Cakes yeah
star crunches nutty uh uh nutty butter
no what's it is it Nutter butter or
Nutty Buddy or Nutty Buddy I thought
Nutty Buddy was the ice cream thing
Nutty Buddy I think is what's called but
I don't remember or Nutter bar Nutter
butter Nutter butter I think
I mean we have a box in there yeah I
could go get it I could just go look at
it
John Robertson said fudge rounds and
Star Crunch still eat them to this day
yeah they yeah they still sell those
gonna say those are probably two of my
least favorite flavors
um yeah that seems like something star
crutches like for you guys don't know
star crush is like it's like a Patty and
it's got
uh
what do you call it it's like terrible
in the middle kind of like chocolatey
caramel in the middle covered in Rice
Krispies with chocolate it tastes like a
like a Reggie bar if you guys remember
what red no no 100 000 bar or 100 gram
bar 100 Grand yeah kind of like that
they still got those too but I think it
might be a cookie it's hard to tell I
think it's a cookie it's not a candy but
it has that same flavor it's real it's
kind of hard in the middle but it's like
it's not quite hard enough to be a
cookie but it's too hard to be terrible
yeah you know it's a it's a I haven't
had one in a while it's a cookie-like
substance
yeah like I said I'm not a big fan of
those I don't really like those I don't
really like the fudge round fudge rounds
are okay they're just kind of I thought
they were always kind of bland I
honestly prefer if I'm gonna get cake I
usually like vanilla cake or a yellow
cake I don't I like chocolate cake I'm
not saying that but it's just like I
usually won't pick that if vanilla is
available
Samantha says love a good oatmeal cookie
my son likes those Pepperidge Farm
Ginger Man gingerbread man the
Pepperidge Farm [__] is all good and
even like Zach said um about the mint
Milanos which is probably my favorite
Pepper charm when I was growing up I was
super into the Chessmen like I loved
those those cookie with chocolate right
yeah it's like it's kind of like those
green and red it's a green cookie I
think no no no no no no it's not great I
thought you could see a little bit of
the cookie sticking out through the
corner no it's the mint Milano it's two
um cookies they almost look like
madeleines and they and then it just has
like a a layer of like kind of a heart
chocolate and then like a white mint in
the middle it's like a sandwich cookie
yeah they have plain Milanos too which
are also good but the mint Milanos are
the [__] this is this is a fat people
conversation it is yeah well we just
kind of got on that because we were
talking about peanut butter cookies
because you made peanut butter cookies
today when I got home yeah that's the
way you made peanut butter cookies and I
made butter chicken anime butter chicken
which is delicious yeah made that
yesterday though yeah we've been eating
a lot for a couple of days well that's
why if you're gonna make Indian food you
might as well make a big huge pot of it
because it's it gets better like a
successive day so you don't get sick of
it you know what I mean day three it's
like man it's better yeah it's like oh
let's have some more yeah I think that's
kind of why I ended up like when we
first moved in together I think that's
why we why I ended up gaining so much
weight because you made so much um good
[__] you made so much Indian food and
it's like a lot of times it was so
delicious you'd be like man I'm gonna go
back and get seconds and then like a
couple hours later I'm gonna go get some
more so you need like four or five bowls
of it like over the course of a day
making all that Thai food too yeah
remember all that Thai shrimp yeah
I still wish I think you made like I
said one time and I can't remember what
it was but you made kind of like a Thai
shrimp soup coconut soup like with
coconut and man oh that was so good
and it's like I don't even remember
where we got that recipe from
the holy [__] that was good yeah holy
[__]
made that your old apartment
yeah that's right
yeah
my old shitty apartment yeah a long time
a long time ago yeah I remember that you
came over and made it yeah
back in the old days back in the ancient
days
slasher friend said do you remember
those classic cookie crisp cereal
commercials with the Rivalry between
cookie Crook and cookie cop I remember
those I kind of do remember those
actually I used to really like Cookie
Crisp I probably still like it nowadays
I haven't had it in a long time I don't
even know if they still sell it but it
had that cookie Jarvis guy right there
yeah yeah cookie Jarvis yeah oh Cookie
Jar oh Cookie Jar I only just got that
he was like he was like the cookie
[__] wizard I was like Jarvis what
does that mean why is that his name that
I was like oh duh yeah he was the cookie
sorry I'm kind of stupid
I can't believe I'm the only person that
remembers Google
I thought I had hallucinated Google
until I Googled it and I was like no I
remember Google
is that you Googled Google yeah Google
it was imitation of flavored peanut
butter
they couldn't call it peanut butter
there wasn't enough peanut butter in it
evidently this is I think they just
called it peanut spread flavored peanut
spread
yeah I guess if you call things a spread
you can get away with a lot of stuff
yeah
kids liked it adults couldn't eat it it
was terrible
well you know had a bunch of different
flavors kids have kind of [__] up
and I have a I have an idea that
what we call Google
is what Europeans call their version of
peanut butter I think their version of
peanut butter is actually Google
because I've never had peanut butter but
evidently
British peanut butter and like maybe
like German peanut butter with the [__]
they would make there it's supposed to
be horrible they don't like it it
doesn't sell
it's probably Google
yeah it's probably like really shitty
people yeah really [__] invitation
because I'm always kind of fascinated by
that because I have heard and I don't
know if this is still the case but I
have heard that they didn't sell like
good peanut butter over there like in
Europe yeah they would sell some other
like weird kind of thing people like ah
Americans eat this [__] gross either we
don't eat that either we have the good
[__] we had a German girl it wasn't
Sandra right yeah Sandra used to be in
here all the time and I and I've talked
about peanut butter so much she was in
Germany she went and got some she got
addicted to it yeah all right she's like
oh yeah she was buying all the different
cons and buying Skippy and Jiff and
Peter Pan is all the important [__] and
they didn't have anything like that in
Germany
so they had peanut butter it was
terrible though and she was she was like
oh well now that I she was like now yeah
now I understand what you're talking
about this shit's great trying to eat it
and everything
mixing it in with ice cream that's oh
we'll see that's always really good
Vanilla Ice you melted a little bit in
the microwave and then pour it over
there like yeah just mixing it with your
ice cream [__] super way better than
chocolate syrup that's for sure yeah I
like ice cream and because I like to
like sprinkle peanuts in there too
peanut butter and vanilla ice cream turn
it into a shake
and blend a [__] banana in there
peanut butter banana shake man see I
like bananas well yeah
well it says isn't peanut butter a good
appetite suppressor
I don't know I don't know I eat a lot of
it so it doesn't work on him it'll work
on me
slasher Fred said it's too bad they
don't show those Hostess commercials on
TV anymore where an animal would mistake
an object for a hostess candy and ask
where's the cream filling oh yeah I kind
of remember those too I mean that's like
a [__] blast from the past I don't
remember that what was that again can we
explain that again Hostess an animal
would do what
would like um mistaken object for
something from Hostess and be like
where's the like I don't remember the
the creamy filling yeah which that has
the potential of
um some real uh sideways situations
let's put it that way
but uh yeah so what else can we talk
about looks like everybody uh enjoyed
the show that we did about the Long
Island serial killer on Friday night
somebody's asked me about Elvis Elvis
and uh peanut butter sandwiches yeah
it's in our in my recipe book that Jenny
printed up for me we got a real good
recipe book that that sandwich is
included it's called Fool's Gold yeah
that's what that's what that's what
Elvis's uh Chef somewhere he used to go
to a special restaurant his favorite
Chef is a buddy of his would make would
make him a sandwich called fool's gold
and it was uh like buttered
French bread or Italian bread a whole
loaf a whole loaf of it cut down the
middle with an entire
jar of peanut butter
on the loaf
uh what else was on it uh was there
jelly on it I think there might have
been yeah and then there was bacon on it
yeah I about to have bacon I think big
or something I go back and look at it
and uh
and uh and he charged a hundred dollars
for that I don't know if it was deep
fried though was it uh I don't think so
I was just fried in a pan yeah it was
pan fried pan fried not deep fried yeah
not one deep fry I'm curious now I'm
sure it's we can find it on the internet
I'm curious how many calories
that has enough to kill you
well probably although he ate them more
than once so yeah
it was a giant how could anybody eat
that much in one sitting
[__] Elvis Man Without
Keeling over
man I always [__] like you know we
used to touch on the subject of Elvis
him being a
Legend to the South and being born in
Tupelo which wasn't really far from
where I lived in Mississippi
everybody there is some kind of a
[__] cousin
and
he moves away and he becomes like a rock
star of the South and then Nationwide
and but he never did a U.S tour I never
did a world tour only toured the U.S
that one movie that we saw about him I
liked it because it was kind of accurate
I think of
the situation Elvis was in
they kept him under tight control
but his decline you know
there have been all kinds of uh these
theories of what had happened to him
he fell and got hurt and then he started
taking
medicine uh what they called medicine
got addicted to pills painkillers that
happens to a lot of people that are in
accidents
and what I believe happened this is my
theory
based on the complaints
it was complaining first of all he
complained he needed his pills all the
time so he was addicted to that and then
he started saying that he had all these
aches and pains in his body and he just
didn't feel right he started to [__]
basically become impotent and he just
lived at the [__] what was the Sands
Hotel what was the name of that hotel
that he lived in I can't remember the
dunes or the sand something like that
and uh
he got pretty weird but one thing about
Elvis is that um when he gained weight
he actually sounded better he sounded
like he could sing like Pavarotti
you need all the room for the sound to
kind of like Echo around in there yeah I
think what happened was he wasn't that
old you know he died young
I think uh those pills had caused him to
reach early and trying to pause and he
hit male menopause it was just [__]
feel like [__]
and uh and he tried to mask it with more
opiates
and you know no you're gonna which makes
it worse and so then you start putting
on a lot of weight especially if you're
eating because you don't have any
testosterone in your system but and if
you start [__] putting a lot of food
on top of that you your cells your cells
just can't [__] metabolize well it
just there's no androgenic signaling
going on in there
oh
Elvis needed drug rehab and he needed
HRT he would have could have [__]
made a comeback now this could Elvis
really should have been famous into his
60s
or his you know if he didn't die he
probably could have made music all the
way to his hands but yeah you would
think yeah but he was only 40 something
I think he was in his early 40s I think
it was when he died
I think it was like 41 or 42. he was
still young yeah
poor guy but nobody nobody you know he
didn't listen to anybody
well that's what happens
uh John Robert said I looked it up
Fool's Gold is 8 000 calories yeah what
was in it again it was peanut butter
I think it might have had banana in it I
thought it was a whole jar of peanut
butter a whole jar heavy jelly there
were some options that sometimes it had
sometimes bacon bacon and maybe banana
on a whole entire Loop yeah I don't
think a hand it was pan frying it may
have had jelly
uh
I don't really remember
8 000 calories that's like probably more
calories than I eat in a week
yeah much less than one sitting
charge him a hundred dollars for that
[Laughter]
probably took up like five minutes to
make it yeah
it's called Fool's Gold I mean that's
the thing it's like that sounds like the
kind of [__] that like and like a 20
year old college guy would make like
after he was drunk like in his dorm room
drunk or high or something like that
it's like I've got a good idea that's
real retro summer [__] though that's
real retro Southern [__] it's like some
[__] my dad would eat yeah John says it
had peanut butter jelly and a pound of
bacon Italian okay yeah Italian right
yeah yeah I know if it was Italian or
French I got the recipe in there and I
think the bacon was optional
evidently I think he had it both ways
with or without the vacant
that's a lot of [__] calories man
yeah like I said that's probably I'm
trying I'm thinking I'm like that's
probably more calories than I eat in a
week yeah
or about the same as I eat the whole
entire week I just want to know was he
eating that in his fat period or when he
was skinny
well if he was eating it was skinny then
we know why he got fat that's for sure
holy [__] I was just reading the um
article not too long ago about
those competitive eaters you know
and how the weird thing is that all of
the top people in those competitive
eating things are all like real skinny
which I don't I don't get I don't get
how that [__] works I was reading the
one about the hot dogs you know what I
mean
where they yeah get they dip the buns in
the water and [__] like that it's
[__] yeah I couldn't eat that many
hot dogs I can't even I can't even watch
yeah yeah hot dogs suck I like hot dogs
it's got to be a beef frank yeah but I'm
not getting I'm not gonna pork is okay
the chicken is chicken Franks man oh I
like turkey ones I used to like turkey
ones I don't like them the texture's raw
yeah the texture is weird but once you
get used to it it's all right because I
used to have um because I used to like
turkey and put it I still eat beef and
stuff but I used to put turkey in like
other stuff you know
yeah Camp guy said they stretch their
stomachs by drinking a lot of fluids for
weeks before that's what I thought
I mean because I was just I don't know I
was thinking well you'd think you'd want
to practice which would make you fat but
I guess not unless they're all bulimic
they just throw it all back up
yeah Victor said Wikipedia says French
bread french bread okay what exactly is
the difference between French bread and
Italian bread french bread if I remember
correctly the I know there's a
difference the French bread had a little
bit of milk inside the uh the Water
oh yeah you're making the culture right
I think it had a little bit of milk in
it maybe that but they're real close
that's what I was thinking they are very
similar and it's like I don't know
like I like if you gave them both to me
and like didn't tell me which one was
which I probably wouldn't be able to
tell the difference
but I knew that there was a difference I
just wasn't sure what it was
gonna have people out there trying to
pick Fool's Gold
well yeah try to eat that I wonder I
could eat a miniature version of that
well yeah that one is the size I could
eat a regular like on sandwich size of
that sure that would actually probably
be really good yeah I'm not gonna eat a
whole [__] loaf of bread in one
sitting though imagine that the the
saltiness of that bacon would mix real
well with the sweetness of that jelly
yeah and then a slight peanut butter
flavor it might and then you have and
then you had to butter both sides of fry
according to Elvis you know Elvis had to
have his uh his uh his P his southern
food cooked in butter and he had to have
a cook who knew it his cook was a
southern black lady that he liked who
lived in there with him and uh because
he cooking just like my mama you know
it's like because you know that's what
Southerners do man just like my mama
yeah they fry everything in butter and
or lard yeah or
bacon grease that was the old diet you
know we still like it
Our Generation was the first generation
to only get about half of it and we
started to break away from it when we
realized
what that does to you over time I mean
it's delicious but yeah okay so there's
that all the time Southerners [__]
food is a religious experience for them
and they get fat
they get yeah big time there's a lot in
common with Southerners and Mexicans
too those little dudes get fat as [__]
if they're not [__] working in those
fields they'll get fat as [__] because
they eat man and Mexican food when done
correctly man it's [__] great got a
real Mexican restaurant over here all
the Farm Workers go in there I go in
there to eat sometimes man it's like a
beautiful guacamole
uh gorgitas tacos [__] all kind of
like carne asada and [__] you know
just baked meats and chicken and soups
and just Mexican food's good
it is yeah yeah but it put some [__]
homemade corn tortillas in there I'm
gonna put some weight on you yeah
I know that's the shitty thing it's like
why does it be so delicious
and why does it have to make you so fat
[Laughter]
all the best stuff is like super bad
thing yeah yeah well your body your body
kind of evolved in times of starvation
and spam and you're in the field [__]
trying to just get something to eat and
if you got something that was high in
protein and fat
and calories that hit the right yep
nerve centers I know this is good eat
more of this because this is this is
what you're looking for well we're now
in the modern world where you can get
[__] unlimited amounts of that [__]
so you can just start
packing it up packing it on
unfortunate yeah
Evolution's a [__] isn't it yeah
just got to be aware of it yeah I mean
like I said you can eat that stuff
you know just in moderation portion
control just like every now and then
like every now and then we'll make like
a big breakfast with like pancakes and
eggs and bacon and stuff like that but
we probably only do that once every few
months or something this is how
ridiculous
Mississippi southerner's word my dad's
generation when he was a baby
well he was a baby his mom would give
him a bottle of milk and put like
four or five tablespoons of [__]
bacon drip is it
bacon grease yeah in the milk
to make them big and healthy good for
you that was the thinking yeah yeah
razor from a bottle with bigger grease
in it yeah
that's why he eating all those [__]
heart bypasses
I know they just weren't really thinking
about that back then were they no if it
tasted good and it was some kind of fat
or some kind of protein that it was good
for you then it was good for you it must
be and if because my grandmother used to
talk like that too yeah and if you got
bigger then it was good for you
didn't matter if it was fat or muscle
just you got bigger so it's good yeah
look how big you are
I'm like that's not always a good thing
not always
but uh but yeah but yeah growing a big
old [__] child bearing hips on those
girls by the time they're 14 they're
getting married at 15. they're [__]
getting their periods or early periods
of [__] 12 and [__] well no that's
not early that's when I got mine okay
like some of my relatives though got him
at like eight or nine yeah which is
super early
and then they're just
that's all that [__] high protein
high fat diet yep that's what that
that's what does that yeah High sexually
charged environment
I'm gonna go get another drink
damn you went through that quick yeah
I'm doing what I do
I wasn't judging I was just making an
observation
slasher friend said one of these days on
your Sunday movie review show you should
review the classic 70s thrill of The
Taking of Pelham One Two Three I had
actually been wanting to I we haven't
done that
I had been meaning to because I had been
wanting to re-watch that
so we might get around to it I don't
know what we're gonna do for the Sunday
show so I don't know if we're gonna
watch something tonight or watch
something tomorrow night or if we're
gonna go to the movies tomorrow I don't
even know if some of the movies because
like I said I want to start
um I want to see uh the last Voyage of
the demeanor but I don't think that
starts for another couple of weeks
did Oppenheimer start
I kind of want to see that although that
is also three hours long
just like but it's Christopher Nolan you
know what I mean so I don't know but I
want to see that so I don't if that's
playing tomorrow we might go see that or
I don't know we might just like pick
something at random
Hollywood chainsaw hookers yeah that's
another good one we did we didn't do
that one either we did frankenhunker
pretty sure
but yeah we haven't done Hollywood
chainsaw hookers yet
we'll find something
we'll find something to talk about which
drama the Sunday movie review okay
Camp guy said I want to see Barbie's
feet
yeah that new Barbie movie looks like
it's uh
smash into all the all the records it is
but yeah okay well it's uh what's your
face from yeah you know what's the what
the hell is her name
I just had it
you know you know who she is yeah yeah
well like I said I thought Oppenheimer
started this week too which actually
looked like um is doing better than they
uh projected you know what I mean what
happened to uh
uh Tom Cruise's movie is it still
kicking ass I guess I don't know
oh I thought that was great
what was the name of that one what was
the name of it Mission Impossible yeah
mission impossible mission impossible
Etc yeah etc etc
dead reckoning part that is what it was
called Margot Robbie thank you
I don't know why I could remember that
don't know why I couldn't remember that
I said oppenheimer's gonna it's good I
said it's gonna be good it looks good we
saw the trailer like last time we were
at the theater
so you know
yeah I just saw that too Zach says
because both those movies are out at the
same time people are calling it
barberheimer
yeah I saw that as well but yeah I don't
know if I I love Margot Robbie but I
don't
I don't know I've heard the Barbie movie
is good but I don't know if I'd like pay
to see it you know what I'm saying I
might watch it when it's like on
streaming yeah I don't think I'll watch
it but
it might I'm sure it's entertaining and
like I said I love her but
I'll probably wait for streaming I'm not
paying to get to see it probably it's a
kids movie though in it is it It's gotta
be yeah I don't think it's a kids movie
all right why wouldn't it be a kids
movie well isn't it supposed to sell
Barbie dolls yeah but I mean I don't
think it's maybe 40 year old women are
buying Barbie dolls now anyway
little girls don't buy that
I don't know I think well they still
have a bunch of them so it's all 40s or
50 year old guys but buying Star Wars
toys yeah but I think little girls still
buy Barbie dolls like far as I know I
don't really know but
but uh Zach says dead reckoning isn't
doing as well as with as they thought
apparently it's weird well it I mean it
costs so much money that it's gonna
really have to like make all the money
too
break even you know what I mean isn't it
like one of the most expensive movies
ever made
I don't know yeah Zach says I guess the
Barbie movie is supposed to be like a
real self-aware dark comedy but still
also for kids lol
yeah and Victor said it's PG-13 same as
Megan
see that's what I thought I didn't get
the impression that it was a kid's movie
at least from like the little Snippets
of the [__] that I've seen
like I said I thought it was like a dark
comedy
um
Barbies have competition and they also
sell themselves to the ones hold I don't
know I don't know it oh the ones whose
moms want them oh okay
I had Barbies when I was a kid not that
many I cut all their hair off and turned
them into punk rockers and stuff but you
know
you know I do
they all got replaced by brats didn't
they and Monster High yeah that's now
I'm gonna say those Monster High dolls
were I would have been all over that
like like white on rice yeah we bought
when I was a kid a friend of our
daughter
yeah oh [__] that was a long time ago
now because we got her four of those
things didn't we yeah
they had that show too like that I never
saw the show little goth dolls
see that was so cool I was just like man
they didn't have that [__] when I was a
kid I feel ripped off
a little bit they had like way cooler
[__] like later on I had some cool [__]
when I was like they did have some I did
have some kind of like monstery toys
when I was a kid like I did have
um the Play-Doh Monster Lab that had
like it was like a mad scientist
laboratory and then it also had
um you could make
it had little um little cookie cutter
things and you could make like mummies
and vampires and [__] like that
so I did have that when I was little and
I had like a game that was called witch
witch or something like that which was
like a little haunted house type
situation it was like 3D like a board
game and I had the Weeble Haunted
Mansion
which somebody like I lost it I guess
like because I had it when I was little
and then I don't know what happened to
it it got lost in moves or something
like that when I grew up and somebody
a friend of the show actually sent me
one that they had bought on eBay so I
have it it's right back there it didn't
have all the stuff like it didn't have
the ghost with it and stuff but it still
had the little witch Weeble and all of
that so I thought that was like super
cool because that was one of my favorite
toys when I was growing up
but yeah
um let's see
yeah John Gore said look like they were
going into Stepford Wives Direction
that's kind of the impression that I got
although I have to say that the remake
of Stepford Wives which came out many
years ago
that had Nicole Kidman in it I really
did not like it I remembered seeing it
in the theater well I mean I love the
original separate wives with Catherine
Ross in them and I love the book by Ira
Levin it's a great book
but I don't know I kind of feel like
they were
the rebates they just made it to I don't
know they just went in the wrong
direction with it I feel like and they
changed it a lot from the book and from
the original story it wasn't really it
wasn't even a Horror Story anymore
really I gotta say most is Hollywood
[__] I don't like it I think it's
stunning is [__] dull
dull and stupid
the best [__] that we've seen was been
like Indie stuff
well like I said that's always been the
case pretty much yeah dead reckoning was
good uh you know there there's always
going to be a couple of Hollywood type
movies that come out a year that are
going to be acceptable or good but most
of them aren't any good
that's why we stopped going to the
[__] AMC Well it's also far away but
I got sick of seeing them things we had
that uh
um
that uh [__] pass what do you call it
yeah
[Music]
that was a good deal I think it was like
it is a good deal 20 bucks a month you
could see three or four movies a week
three movies a week which like I said
you only have to see like two movies
yeah it'll make it worth it and it could
be the Dolby or whatever yeah it didn't
matter
and uh and you got free perks too like
five dollars off drinks and [__] like
that well Jen was working from home in
those days so we would go to the matinee
yeah yeah I like I like going there when
it's dead yeah I do too I don't like the
life like crowds the less people the
better yeah we have the whole theater to
ourselves in the damn Dolby Theater
[Laughter]
and uh
most of those movies were totally
forgettable
there were some of them that were really
good but uh
you know
maybe 10 of them
yeah maybe 10 15 maybe
most of them were just kind of
forgettable
that happens a lot I mean because I kind
of feel like it's really really hard for
a movie and this is goes for any era
because I kind of feel like a lot of
movies that I saw when I was growing up
were just kind of like meh yeah I mean
like a lot of them you didn't really
remember they were just kind of whatever
Zack said I learned recently there was a
remake of dead ringers yeah I heard
about that as a streaming series on Hulu
but the twins are gender swaps and
Rachel Weiss plays them yeah I had
actually been wanting to see that it
looked pretty cool it looked like they
did a diff slightly different Direction
with it maybe but yeah they made it into
a series and I was kind of like oh that
sounds like something I might want to
get involved in so I might I don't know
I might end up watching that and like
doing a review for my other channel
maybe yeah
out of the ones that we saw almost all
those Marvel movies were forgettable I
didn't dislike them at the time watching
them just couldn't remember anything
about them when they were over
um
well let's see what else was uh
the ones that I did remember though were
ones that were just like
art of self-defense Jenny thought I was
gonna hate that movie I [__] loved it
um
trying to think of some of the other
ones just pop out at me
well the uh the uh the Keanu Reeves
movies the what was just what's the uh
John Wick movies yeah we still haven't
seen the fourth one no I haven't seen it
and then uh those saw those in the
theater they were [__] great
James Bond in the theater
they're great
um
but just a lot of them were just real
forgettable
we saw mid-summer yeah in the theater
that was I liked that one a lot yeah we
saw that twice I think yeah now that I'm
thinking about it I liked I also liked
uh us the Jordan peel movie I think we
saw that a couple I think we saw that
twice yeah we saw that twice it's pretty
good although a lot of his other stuff I
didn't like I just liked that one it was
okay it was weird I like to get out a
little bit better but us was real good
too I didn't like nope as much as either
of those though because like I said it's
aliens and that's not usually my deal
but um
Camp guy said is that the Jeremy Irons
movie yeah it's um
is David kronenberg and uh he made it in
I think it was 1988 it's actually one of
my favorite Cronenberg movies like
Jeremy Irons one of his best
performances I mean there's kind of a
lot of competition there because he's
always good but he was really good at
that we saw that Cronenberg movie we
were the uh there was only one other guy
in the theater with us yeah it was like
he's like he was like there by himself
he was there by Crimes of the future
that was the future we watched that [__]
when it was over he stood up and he was
like what the [__] was that
was cronerberg
I kind of feel like well David
Cronenberg he's like he's not happy
unless everybody gets up at the end of
this movie like what the [__] did I just
watch he's just like thank you I've done
my job Pat yourself on the back Dave
yeah that's what he's got a big old Baby
Huey dude that he probably was six times
you turn around and looked at school
what the [__] was that
why are there vaginas in their stuff I
get it
I liked that movie
you know what I'm gonna say though that
I think I liked uh infinity pool a
little bit better the Brandon Cronenberg
one the Brandon Cronenberg yeah it was
pretty good I liked that a lot I was
thinking about that a lot
I tell you what that Keanu Reeves had
that movie that bombed like [__]
crazy but I loved it there's the one
about the genetic engineering and turned
out his face I remember that it just it
instantly what yeah it was it had like a
real generic set of replicas or replica
or something yeah there's replicas and
it was like in the theater and out in
like a few days it bombed so badly I
don't even think people remember it yeah
and we saw it because we were saying
they tried to hide it
it was pretty [__] tacky but it had
some of the worst [__] CG I've seen
remember the CG it was pretty terrible
terrible but I liked it I was just like
for a movie of that caliber yeah it was
kind of like
kind of like something [__] from the
from the early 90s like a tacky Arnold
Schwarzenegger movie yeah it seemed like
it came from another era which was what
was weird about it yeah which was also
kind of like because remember that other
movie that we went to see that you
really liked the the one about the
couple that had like the weird um that
had the Quade you know
what is the coin yeah you know Dennis
Quaid yeah and he was like he was the
sold the couple the house and then he
was like oh yeah yeah yeah I like that
one that one was like a lifetime movie
from hell and I was there for it yeah
yeah because they leaned right into that
[__] yeah it was it was that guy named
Dennis Quaid right yeah
story with that creepy like Grinchy
smile that he had
a story about this black couple they're
like these professionals I think he's a
doctor or she's a doctor I can't
remember now yeah they both had like
super at both jobs these high
caliber
jobs
and they bought it from this old white
dude
who's his family's uh they died right
yeah his wife his kids died or something
and he's like well I'm sure they're
going to miss this house so I'm glad
that you guys got it and everything and
he leaves
turns out he didn't leave me he still
was living in the house with bunny
rabbit head yeah he was he had he had
like a whole warrant of [__] tunnels
and [__] he was living inside the house
he was stalking the wife this the wife
was fine yeah I don't you got what was
the name of the uh
but they're like doing kind of like
love scenes between her and the husband
and he's [__] peeping at him through
[__] little cracks in the walls and
[__] I mean he can't go wrong with
Thrillers like that yeah because it's
just like that's such a creepy premise
yeah inherently it's hard to [__] that
it was good it was only the whole movie
only had like three people in it I liked
it though like I said because it was
trashy but it knew that it was trashy
and it knew that you knew that it was
trashy and it wasn't like trying to be
it was anything more than it was trying
to get this [__] over with
and Dennis Quaid looked like he was
having the time of his life man yeah he
was like chewing up that [__] thing
yeah yeah it was great he played the
ultimate [__] villain and [__] he's
Hamming it up yeah he was [__] great
like I said I really like that creepy
smile that he had to look like the
[__] Grinch you know what I mean like
the animated Grinch were his little not
the [__] Jim Carrey what was the name
of that movie you guys can put it in the
comments I think it's Intruder and it
should have just called intrina the
Intruder yeah
Julian said have y'all ever done a
review of psycho I think we did didn't
we do like a mega review of all four of
the psycho ones yeah I think we did
because we got all of them in a box set
yeah and I'm pretty sure that we did all
of them like on one video yeah that
whole series is good
yeah every single one of them yeah
and I will go to that I mean psycho
obviously the first one's a classic but
I will go to bat for psycho too that is
a great [__] movie and honestly it
shouldn't have worked at all because
look how long it was when did psycho 2
come out early 80s
and look how long it was it was like 20
something years like between the
original coming out and the second one
coming out and you know it absolutely
should not have worked but it totally
did I mean Seiko 2 is like really really
good and the other the other ones are
good too yeah
Anthony Perkins yeah he was producing
those I think yeah and he was taking
that uh well he was taking that role
that character further what's funny
about him
is that we saw a documentary on Anthony
Perkins
and I figured he was gay but it turns
out they said yeah he was gay and he his
boyfriend was another famous like Idol a
hero actor type dude he's like one of
the best looking guys in Hollywood that
was his boyfriend turned out he was kind
of being molested by his mom in real
life
and evidently that kind of informed yeah
that's what we heard yeah that's what he
said right yeah yeah
which is [__] up yeah Anthony
perkins's mom was and she was an actress
I think
wasn't she yeah
I think she was an actress too now the
fourth one was kind of like where I
think that was kind of where the jumping
off plays for Bates Motel was because
that was kind of like
um like a prequel like it was showing
Norman like right you know and it was
absolutely like a younger actor playing
him
um but yeah Zach said the moment I
realized the actors playing Mrs Bates in
psycho4 was Juliet in the 60s Romeo and
Juliet yeah yeah it's Olivia Hussey she
was also in Black Christmas so there's
that she got famous though playing uh
Juliet in Romeo and Juliet the what is
it zepharelli or yeah the world famous
one I think she got it did she get Oscar
for that or something she got like some
kind of a word or something
but uh yeah Camp guy said that too just
about all those Psycho movies are pretty
good they are actually I think three is
the weakest one but um but they're all
like totally worth watching and
um John Robertson said in my opinion
psycho 2 is almost better than psycho
yeah I mean on some days
I might be a client inclined to agree
with you because like I said psycho is a
classic obviously but they're all good
Seiko 2 is like just a million times
better than it had any right to be and I
just love that that happened you know
yeah Sebastian said in the psycho review
Tom's wearing the snake blitzkin t-shirt
well there you go somebody just went and
looked at it okay yeah I got a bunch of
these yeah yeah he he makes new ones
like every time
yeah throw the old ones out I'll wear
them out
they're like work shirts to me you go
into my [__] closet look it up it's
nothing but black t-shirts hug up it's
like some Smurfette actually it's just
like all of it I want to wear today I
gotta make some new [__]
yeah we do like but yeah I just haven't
had time to get a route to it
Victor said oh it was Tab Hunter was
that who was that who he was
um who Tony Perkins was with yeah I
think it was yeah oh [__] I didn't know
that okay I know who Tab Hunter is
um [__] I just saw something the other
day with [__] Tab Hunter in it yeah
they were the undercover in the closet
[__] gay power couple of Hollywood
well you had to be back then yeah Tab
Hunter was hugely famous
like in the 50s and 60s
and then he was in some [__] later on
too because I remember he was in he was
in Greece too he played the [__] he
played the [__] science teacher that
sang that reproduction song but he was
in other [__] too
was it was he at the first Grease I
think he was just in this I don't know I
think he was just in the second one
I think that was the first time that I'd
seen him
murder Hornet said black Christmas was
the first slasher movie I you know I'm
not gonna argue with you about that but
I'm gonna say I think the first slasher
movie was Bay of blood
which came out in 1971.
Mario Baba also called twitch of the
Dead death nerve it's not exactly like a
slasher movie because there's
technically not one killer there's
several but the way that it is shot
looks very much like a slasher movie and
I will note that Friday the 13th the
Friday 13th series straight up stole two
scenes from Bay of blood including the
very iconic one where the you know the
the two people are having sex and like
they Jason like stabs the spear like
through then like all the way through
that's straight up stolen right from Bay
of blood that's it's almost exactly the
same shot exactly the same and what was
the other scene I can't remember what
the other scene was maybe the ax to the
face
from the first one but um but yeah it's
like and it's shot the same they did it
on purpose but you know what I mean
especially that spear kill but that's
right from Bay of blood so I would argue
that bay of blood is the first slasher
movie but I'm not gonna like because
black Christmas was kind of the first
one that cemented and that was for sure
like the first holiday slasher that uh
you know that girl you're talking about
that uh
got stabbed through the bed on the bed
in that Friday the 13th scene you're
talking about were they ripped off that
scene from that from the Italian movie
Italian flick
in that first one she's kind of like one
of the one of the uh one of the hotties
in the
show
never [__] I need to go take some of
that Benadryl my [__] nose is stuffed
up like crazy can we talk about that
he's got like a he's got his stuffed up
nose or something like that and last
night he gets in bed he's like man I
take some Benadryl and uh then he's like
and I didn't know how many to take on
the back of the bottle or whatever yeah
because it was too small for him to see
and I was like well how many did you
take and he's like six I was like what
and then he was I was like what you mean
you took six like over the course of a
day no I just took six just right now I
was like you just took six Benadryl yeah
didn't make any difference
same as taking two
I was like technically you're really on
this baby what I was gonna say is that
girl
that was in that movie the one that got
killed in the bed with the other guy and
I thought that guy was uh
[__] what's his name wouldn't it
Kevin Bacon Kevin Bacon it was Kevin
Bacon it's got uh stabbed long weather
that girl evidently uh she was well now
he got stabbed through the neck okay
there's another guy that got stabbed
with her did that girl from the movie
she was evidently pretty troubled at the
time
trying to get work and she ended up
becoming a
drug addict and uh there's part of her
out and [__] you can find it and she
looks [__] terrible
like a crackhead she's got all her teeth
but you could see you know she's on
something and uh she was doing porn and
then I think it was 90s or very early
2000s when she was like in her
late 30s early 40s or something but uh
because we were talking about that one
day and I [__] was looking up that
cast and see who ended up where and
there was a yeah I think the last time
we were watching those movies because we
got the box set and how long yeah
well it says what happens to all those
people yeah
what happened to all those actors in
real life most of them were okay but
that particular one she uh
went down a bad path to I think she was
homeless and disappeared I think with
the last thing that they said thanks
yeah that's shitty
Victor says Tab Hunter said his agent
was the only person he trusted because
he was the only person who didn't try to
sleep with him oh
John Robertson said am I the only one
that just wants to see Anthony Perkins
as Norman Bates and just see him live
his life and that be the whole movie I
would probably watch that
can owned that character man I mean he's
great in other things he's like creative
yeah I've seen him in other things too
and he's always great but he was
actually the funny thing about it I
can't remember what year it came out and
I've been wanting to do a review of it
for a while but he was in sort of like a
psycho rip-off movie or like you know a
crazy guy movie that was called
I think it was called how awful about
Alan or something like that this is who
Perkins yeah Anthony Perkins so he and
also he was in one called like what the
[__] yeah edge of Sanity yeah yeah yeah
I remember seeing that one on cable it
was okay yeah it was pretty I remember
it being pretty good I haven't seen it
for many years it might it might suck on
toast but probably not like I always
liked seeing him but I kind of feel like
him being in Psycho yeah that's gonna
Typecast you a little bit but he was so
good at playing
that kind of role it was kind of like
Leonard Nimoy and Spock yeah Leonard
Leonard [__] helped create Spock a
lot of the a lot of the [__] episodes
that was back when the actress could
have input and go to the writers go this
is the way the character really should
be and they're like yeah yeah we'll go
with that but it's like a collaboration
like a collaboration yeah so
Leonard the more I created the [__]
spot character because it when it
started it wasn't really decided who
Spock was he was just a generic alien
and we just seen the pilot episode
Leonard to my playing Spock it's a
totally different character yeah
yeah there's no mention of him not you
know keeping his emotions under control
or anything he's just he's just a
regular guy
um
well that was the same that was the same
thing with uh Norman Bates
that's a lot of Anthony Perkins in there
him and Hitchcock [__] cooked a lot
of that [__] up how that character
should be I think the great thing about
him is that he's clearly insane
but he's also really sympathetic
he's like a dual Personality yeah like
you could totally see how somebody would
and that and that's the thing like he's
really awkward but he's not super
off-putting and it's just like I don't
know it's like a really hard balance to
pull off but he totally did it
and I think that's what makes the second
one so good too because if you haven't
seen the second one the whole premise of
the second one is that you know it's set
in the year that it was made which I
think was 81 or something like that
maybe it was a little 80 jail
but he just got out of the mental
hospital and he's going back to the
hotel and he's running it again and
obviously like everybody's freaking out
because it's like they don't want him
back out and all this other kind of
stuff and then all of these people end
up murdered and it seems like he's the
one doing it and they're almost kind of
like trying to so so it's kind of cool
the way he seemed he's seemingly cured
and he's out but then it's almost kind
of like the townsfolk are kind of like
gun informed like push him back into it
again so I think it was like a really
good idea to like explore it from that
angle because like I said he comes
across as like even more sympathetic in
the second one because it's like he just
wants to get back to his regular life
but no one will let him you know what I
mean because of all the [__] that he did
so it's I don't know like it really
tackles like some big issues I guess
like would you ever feel safe around
this guy like after you knew what he did
and after you know they said he was okay
and they let him out but
you know would you want to live next
door to him or would you stay at his
hotel or anything like that you know
um let's see Leonard Nimoy an Invasion
of the Body Snatchers he was so good in
that like it was kind of a I mean it
wasn't anything like a spot character he
was almost kind of like a like a cheese
dick
psychotherapist type and he was so good
in that I loved dick that's my favorite
version of that book because if you
didn't know like I said that's based on
a Jack Finney novel Body Snatchers and
that's been made into a movie
four times
it was made once in the 50s it was made
in 1978 which is my favorite one that's
the Philip Kaufman one with Leonard
Nimoy in it and then it was made again I
think Abel Ferreira did a version of it
in the 90s 94 something like that and
then there was another version I think
in 2007 that maybe had Nicole Kidman and
I want to say that was just called
Invasion I haven't seen that one
actually I haven't seen the Abel
Ferreira one either I've heard that one
was pretty good but I haven't seen it I
didn't even realize that he had made a
version of Invasion of the Body
Snatchers but I think he changed like
some things
um
yeah Victor Garcia started Kathleen
Turner and Serial Mom do a review of
that movie man that's another good one
that I haven't got that's a John Waters
um and I love that movie I love Kathleen
Turner anyway
um
so that would probably that might be a
good one she was in Romance of the stone
once you yeah yeah we saw that did we
review romance in the stone I think we
saw it we watched it not too long yeah
it was it was pretty good I Remember
Loving that yeah it's pretty good and
like I said there's a there's a sequel
too yeah
um Jewel of the Nile
yeah I forgot about that one yeah they
were on cable all the time I must have
seen those movies like 400 times when I
was growing up they were ripoff Indiana
Jones yeah yeah well that was kind of
like a big thing but after Indiana Jones
got so popular yeah like everybody was
doing these big like adventure movies
yeah which you know that's fine but um
yeah I really liked Romancing the Stone
Jewel of the night was pretty good too I
remember I haven't seen that one in a
long time but we did watch mermaid thing
this down I really liked Kathleen Turner
in
the Man with Two Brains
which is one of my very favorite
underrated comedies from the 1980s with
Steve Martin
because I love the premise of it the
premise of it is just so ridiculous and
they almost kind of like play it
completely straight which is [__]
hilarious to me and Kathleen Turner
David Warner's in it too
Kathleen Turner just plays a complete
[__] I mean she is and she just looks
like she's having a [__] great time
doing it she's just a total gold digging
[__] and it's awesome but yeah she's
like so so good at it
but yeah we should do cereal mom or
somebody was saying um body heat too
that's another good Kathleen Turner one
we still haven't done body heat that was
another one that we need to do
I need one thing that we can complain
about all the new movies that they make
now and the [__] that they make now it
doesn't matter there's two lifetimes of
good movies you can watch and television
programs are made over the [__]
decades that's what I'm saying it's just
like I'll never run out of good [__] to
watch so I don't I don't waste time like
bitching about oh this thing came out I
don't like it or whatever because it
seems like I was like but there's these
million other things yeah some of the
entertainment podcasts or entertainment
YouTube shows that I listen to the guys
that
host of those shows are a little bit
younger than me 40s
and uh they have kids that are late
teens
and they're just they find it to be
incredible because without any kind of
prompting their kids are get into the
same [__] they that our generation got
into they're listening to classic music
and don't they're not listening to
anything beyond [__] the two uh like
the 90s the 2000s you know I think that
one guy said the the newest thing that
his son will listen to is Linkin Park
anything other than that is old stuff
and the same thing with all the movies
they watch all the old movies
and
and he says it's funny he'll come up he
goes dad have you ever heard of a band
called Led Zeppelin
they're great
like I said they haven't been here long
but it's just like so funny it's like
all right youngster dad there's this
great movie man it's called Terminator
two
and they just started called aliens yeah
there's this movie it's bad
this [__] is called the thing it's
called The Thing
[__] do it yeah that's like that's
hilarious yeah I just never thought that
I would see that it's just like so funny
that's so funny yeah and evidently do it
unprompted it's just uh
that's what
kids in their late teens think is really
cool because it is there was the the
best of our products that we grew up
with in that era were real
artistic Works artistic like like the
[__] the thing that was that was that
was from the heart that wasn't some
corporate [__]
uh [__]
uh
a bunch of corporate [__] suits
trying to figure out demographics and
how the movie it's just some it was just
some dudes going yeah we're gonna make
this badass flick you know it's just
it's very analog you know natural can we
have a severed head with spider spider
legs I would love that
it's one of the best movies of all time
is predator one it was just written by
some ex-infantry guys and they slid that
[__] they slid the story underneath
the [__] door of some guys who were
gonna produce some [__] they made the
movie
they got the idea from an old movie that
was that I remember seeing as a kid
called without warning yeah yeah yeah
that's where they got the idea yes
without warning was kind of like a
kind of like your typical Friday the
13th slasher flick but instead of having
a Jason they had an alien that was
running around hunting teenagers and
people
and it was he had these little throwing
objects it was like a it was like a
pentagon
he could throw it but it was alive and
[__] tentacles would come out of it
when it hit you and it would grab onto
and it had a [__] mouth of these
teeth and it'd start eating on you I
feel like that was from a movie from the
50s like it conquered the world or
something it was called didn't the alien
from the 50s movie have like little like
bat things that would like suck on the
back of your neck and like suck out your
personality yeah maybe I don't remember
I think I'm pretty sure
but uh it was and the alien actually
looked pretty good and he had a shack he
was he's hanging a lot of the bodies up
in the shacks and making trophies out of
them
as one does yeah you haven't seen it
have you I saw it a long time ago yeah I
saw it a long time ago I kind of
remember it wouldn't mind seeing it
again
maybe that's another one we should do
there's like see there's like a million
recommendations and it's like so back in
the 80s some army guys saw that this
goes yeah that's a cool idea but why
would it be hunting down teenagers
they'd be hunting down something
you know uh [__] more formidable like
some badass soldiers and they came up
with well yeah because that's going to
make the enemy like the monster look a
lot more about a lot more badass yeah
he's not after teenagers and old men
because he thought he was killing
teenagers and Old Men
so we're just like I said hey guys that
threatening yeah where's the threat yeah
but it's like if it can if like [__]
a dude like [__] special forces dudes
are [__] in their pants yeah then that's
some scary [__]
for those guys right going after the
[__] baddest of the bad and just
watching them kill other dudes in that
big raid trying to figure out which ones
are the [__] baddest ones and who's
dominant over other who's dominant over
the other ones on that same team and try
to [__] prioritize who's the biggest
fish
yeah
and there's a whole theme of [__]
Predator one is that there's always a
bigger fish they show you a big dude and
then another big dude and then a big
dude and a big dude a big dude and then
a big dude that is bigger than the big
dudes because he's a [__] alien okay
no matter how big you are there's
something else gonna come [__] get
you this is that's just nature you know
that's that's uh don't get too up
yourself don't get too [__] [__]
because there's something out there that
can kick you out yeah guarantee it
John Robertson says I'm 22 years old and
love all things considered old but
Gothic [__] is the best thing that I
love
we love Gothic [__] yeah and honestly
even when I was growing up and if we
talk about this a lot because I was like
it's really weird because when we were
growing up in the 80s
um it was kind of considered uncool like
to like the same [__] that your parents
likes there's still like a generation
gap yeah I think Gen X was kind of the
last I think it had started to erode a
little bit after that it was lame man
that's true well not by me my parents
like some cool shows my dad likes some
cool music he likes some shitty music
too but he like like some cool [__]
mostly but the thing about it was that
when I was younger I didn't really have
a thing I did have the kind of thing
it's like oh you know old people music
or whatever but I didn't really have
that like I liked old silent movies I
liked like [__] from the 1950s I like so
I didn't have like a stigma about oh
that's old like I you know I can't watch
it or anything like that and I and that
was like before the internet and
everything now with me it was closed the
clothes and the [__] music that your
parents liked sucked yeah mine did my
mom listened to Barry Manilow and [__]
you know although I could popping their
collars up I kind of like very much
preppy clothes I couldn't [__] hated
that [__] although I don't I still don't
like practically yeah the popping
collars like people are still doing that
it's ridiculous
they pop collars and like cargo shorts
and Crocs
docksiders and [__] yeah terrible it is
terrible
it is terrible but what I was well what
I was thinking is like because of the
Advent of the Internet it's now
everything is just kind of out there
yeah you can get it so you can just get
it so it's not like
you know you could just come across a
song for example and it's like you don't
necessarily know how old that is you're
just like oh that's like a cool so like
if you don't know anything about it like
I said it's just like the kid like
discovering Led Zeppelin it's like if
you just heard that one day it's like oh
that's pretty cool yeah it's like you
wouldn't necessarily know that that was
from the 60s yeah who was that though
saying that it was 22 likes John
Robertson John yeah nothing John about
old products from that era that you're
talking about like old goth stuff it was
all kind of handmade basically
and uh
you know I wasn't made with anything
high technology
so everything was kind of
down to earth and kind of realistic so
if you saw somebody who's dressed up
fantastic some punk rock chick
you could if you break overall it'd be
kind of impressive looking you break it
down what she's going on and a lot of
that stuff is just made by hand or cut
to me to to change into shape or
something and they just took
Clippers and started cutting out pieces
of their hair and have their friends do
stuff and it was just all do it yourself
it wasn't store-bought do-it-yourself
stuff you just you couldn't go to store
to buy any of that they didn't sell that
and you know
you had some catalogs you could order
from like black rose and stuff
over in England it took forever to get
to get it to you and they had but you
couldn't go anywhere to buy golf clothes
not really yeah you had to make them
yeah or what I used to do is I used to
go to like thrift stores yeah and you'd
find like some old lady like black
dresses like some old lady had died or
something and like they you know they
gave all her [__] to the thrift store
and so you bought all that or you went
to the Army Navy store and like bought
old boots and [__] yeah and then you
just kind of had to cut it and put
patches on it and all that other kind of
stuff to make it look yeah original we
were doing that in the 70s and the 80s
and the stuff that we were buying was
old but it was like from the 30s and the
40s and the 50s you know sometimes 60s
all that stuff would be gone now you
couldn't do that today
well this ever well people discovered
thrifting in the 90s yeah and so after
that they bought up all the good [__]
one and then two now they still have
thrift stores but now they charge more
money yeah because they're like now it's
vintage he used to be able to go and
find [__] badass work boots from the
30s
made out of horse hide horse leather and
[__] they looked damn near brand new
but you could tell those things were
damn near 100 years old but they were
built to last real [__] heavy
materials and stuff real heavy leather
and stuff made made really well they
just don't make things like that anymore
if they did it would be like 400 item
you just made real well
Victor says cargo shorts and Crocs is my
everyday outfit
and then John Robertson is talking about
favorite episode of Night Gallery return
to the sorcerer with Vincent Price and
it's one of the better ones and of
course the cemetery from the pilot I
love that [__] pilot yeah I've been
doing
um
I did a review on my other channel scare
Salon uh of the Night Gallery pilot I
did that as a video and then I did the
first season as a video and I still have
the other two I've seen them before but
I'm gonna do like another re-watch and
like do a video of each because I still
have I bought the box set like a couple
months ago so I've been going through
that and I've also been going through
Thriller the Boris Karloff show
and I still have another season of that
to go
that was only two seasons but it's long
like they had a lot of episodes so I did
the first season and I finally finished
that also like a dumbass I also said
that I was gonna get into Kolchak The
Night Stalker I did the two movies but I
haven't done any of the series yet but
eventually I want to get into that as
well because I wanted to re-watch that
too so
I'm making a lot of work for myself yeah
as you can see okay if you're listening
to this program
um recorded we got the super thanks is
activated and of course uh super chats
are activated too
John Robertson also says Tom I found a
comic book version of Dracula that is
100 accurate to the novel yeah they use
Bella Lugosi with his son's blessing you
might like it huh okay that sounds
pretty cool actually it's a comic book
yeah okay they drew Bella goes yeah yeah
I had one when I was a kid that was like
a I mean it was kind of like a Cliff's
Notes version but it was like I mean the
drawings were nice and everything like
that but dude if you haven't seen
Spanish Dracula see it
yeah we did a review of that we did the
universal the bellagosi Dracula and then
we also did the Spanish track yeah in
case you didn't know when they made the
Bell Lugosi Dracula
they also made a Spanish version of it
yeah they did that a lot back in the
same company did it was so they didn't
take the English version and dub it they
made a different one and they on the
same set and they were being made at the
same time the same sets and actually
the Spanish one is better
the only thing that's
the way a shot is better
you see how 3D those sets were they
moved through them uh Dracula's Brides
there's more of that in there
they didn't cut a lot of stuff out like
they did from the other drive from our
Dracula
the guy who plays their Dracula is a
Spanish actor and he has a different
take on the character
he's weird he's a little more over the
top he's a little over the top almost I
think he was doing a little bit more
like Max Shrek from [__]
Nosferatu he's kind of doing it more
like that but he doesn't look like that
with his facial expressions his eyes
were you know yeah very silent movie
yeah like something out of the silent
oop like very very oh like but it's in
its Spanish dialogue with English
subtitles yeah John Robertson said I saw
Spanish version of Dracula and I like it
better yeah a lot of people do a lot of
people do but I would never give up
lugosi's version are you they're both
real good
um
but I like Spanish but I Dracula better
I think I mean the way like I said I if
they have the Spanish version but with
Bella Lugosi in it I think that would be
the perfect Dragon because I do like the
way that the Spanish word it's like it's
more Dynamic there's more in it yeah
it's a little more salacious yeah they
didn't cut out as much stuff because
they didn't have the same problem with
censorship that they had in the United
States you also have better special
effects it shows walking through the
[__] giant spider web yeah and he
doesn't ever touch it I liked that
because it was like real subtle yeah but
it's like you had to be paying attention
to see that he did that
uh Johnson says Christopher Lee is
always going to be my favorite Dracula
man I love Christopher Lee
we did a whole wait did we we had a show
about Christopher Lee and Peter Cushing
didn't we
I think we did we did we did we did a
Christopher Lee and Peter Cushing show
we did a Bella Lugosi and Boris Karloff
show and recently we did events
impression
that's another movie that we should do
is speaking of Mac Shrek is shadow of
the vampire yeah
which is like I said not a horror movie
necessarily I don't know what I'd call
it what genre is it
but it's basically about maybe it's a
black comedy I don't know if I want to
call it a black comedy
oh it's kind of funny but like in a dark
way it's John Malkovich and um Willem
Dafoe Willem Dafoe plays Max Shrek and
like I said the whole
premise of the movie
is that it's based around the making of
Nosferatu in the 20s but the whole
premise of the movie is that Max Shrek
is actually a vampire and that FW murnau
got him to be in the movie for very
similitated purposes and wouldn't tell
the rest of the cast
so he's like eating them and stuff so
like I said it sounds zany it's not zany
though like I said it's kind of funny
but like in a really dark kind of grim
way it's a great [__] movie I saw it
in the theater when it came out
Zach says uh Gary Oldman is my favorite
Dracula he was a great one too actually
even though he only really played him
once but
I don't know I
it would be hard for me to pick between
bellagosi and Christopher Lee because
they had it such a different take on it
I really like Christopher Lee was a lot
scarier because he was big and he was
imposing yeah he's a lot more physical
yeah he looked yeah like the physicality
of him is a lot more whereas Bella
Lugosi was kind of more like a like
hypnotizing or like more like Suave he
and he was kind of like it was implied
violence yeah he didn't really
demonstrate it he was just he was just I
couldn't [__] you up you know he's like
he's like that but you weren't sure how
he would do it
you know you're [__] pull again he
Jenny was saying that she would probably
like to have Bella Lugosi in the Spanish
Dracula and be the ultimate
in some ways I'd say yeah yeah but it's
also kind of a discredit to the Spanish
actor that did Dracula I liked his take
on Dracula 2. I did too had I not seen
Bella and just seen him and first and
then seen Bella afterwards I probably I
would have liked them both but I might
have favored the Spanish guy over that
hit
it's just a different take on Dracula
it's a different tone yeah but it is
weird he's weird I like that he didn't
he he didn't try to copy Billy goes no
he just did his own thing did his own
thing and it and it seems to be more
like something Max Shrek would have done
okay you probably watched a little cut
of [__] nosferata yeah and like some
out of the silent movies and now
serachi's still creepy I don't care what
you say
that dude was creepy as [__]
you know what I mean I think that's
probably why they where they got the
idea to make Shadow of the vampire
because they're like that dude look
legit looked like a real [__] man now
that I'm bald I could do a badass
[__] Nosferatu costume oh my God you
should that would be oh yeah I get the
[__] long ears and get the ears and
the little [__] front teeth oh that'd
be so awesome like a [__] rat
or you could be Mr Barlow yeah the Mr
Barlow that ooh that would be even
better yeah just go blue but yeah that
dude was so skinny I'd be jacked Mr
Barlow
my [__] Kate backs nothing but pecs
let me see everybody you could be like
WrestleMania man Mr Marla
uh hey Dave what's going on big little
there's you getting ready to go out
tonight May check out conduit yeah
that's I still haven't been there I know
they're doing like a lot of shows there
conduit where is that that's where
remember where the Haven used to be in
Winter Park Haven yeah that was like
where Amani's like she would have all
his bands play there yeah it's there
that was the old metal Club yeah yeah
okay I've been here a long time yeah
they're doing like Golf shows and stuff
now okay
uh is is Imani behind that I don't know
well I've just I've done a couple
posters for it but that was um Mark in
Tampa okay like setting that up so it's
mostly like who's playing there tonight
I don't know
even though I did posters but I don't
remember because I do so many how's
mannequin's been the online information
I'm getting from [__] about with
mannequins is that mannequins is a
[__] [__] show well we need to slap
and [__] people and [__] punching
people in the face is that yeah is that
what happened because I heard I didn't
get the whole Scuttle butt yeah I kept
seeing everybody like the following day
we weren't there that night but the
following day like everybody was talking
about it but nobody was talking about
what it was like what exactly happened
you know what I mean and everybody was
like posting all of these cryptic and I
was like what the [__] is going on yeah
mannequins man we were talking about
Predator movie earlier and I said the
the moral behind the the lesson of
Predator one is that there's always a
bigger fish which is kind of keeping me
from going to mannequins because every
time I go with mannequins I gotta fight
it's crazier than me
yeah because you never know who's going
to be in there that's why I'm sorry like
I like that place but I'm always kind of
like on edge the whole time I'm there
because I'm like you never know who's
gonna wander in there and like he's
gonna cause trouble and it's like oh
this is gonna be bad
um Dave said yeah it was not good yeah
yeah that's what you don't want to say
is is is is is mannequin still going to
be a thing or are people going to
gravitate away from that gonna happen
all right
but I like mannequins it's just they
need more security to keep certain
people out
yeah you can't have [__] dudes in
there throwing their weight around
[__] intimidating people on the dance
floor and [__] because well yeah because
the morning Jen's ass the more you let
people get away with that the more it's
going to get around and people are gonna
be like oh you can do whatever the [__]
you want to in there yeah you're just
gonna escalate you're right you know
what I mean right so you can't you gotta
nip that [__] in the butt you gotta nip
it in the bud yeah and Florida is now a
concealed carry state
you don't need to you don't need a
license to conceal a weapon here
talking about firearms
now it's you cannot legally take
a firearm into a place that serves
alcohol
so you can't go into a bar with one
but these [__] don't give a
[__] they'll go in there one
that's what I mean even remember now
well and I I was thinking that there's
Outlaw Bikers around there which is
actually those guys are not the problem
yeah I would I would worry less about
them I'm not worried about biker gangs
yeah it's just uh
it's dude Bros I'm worried about yeah
dude Bros yeah biker gang's actually
fine yeah they're they're pretty chill
yeah honestly we used to go when they
had venue 13 at that biker bar it was
like half biker gangs and like half Goss
and it was fine yeah it was the warlocks
yeah it was fine yeah like ever like the
bikers would be respectable yeah they
would be like look at those weirdos over
there but they never said anything they
never did anything but then a warlock
comes in with his girlfriend he's got
her on her leash and [__] puts her up
on the pole as a stripper girlfriend
that's cool yeah so they got the same
thing they just do a little bit
different like I said yeah I I think
they they realize that it's like it's
not the the scenes are not really that
different yeah I have never been scared
of bikers no that's they're a subculture
to themselves they know the rules well I
grew up in Daytona it's like a big biker
Enclave yeah
um so I was around bikers a lot it's
like they were always like in town and
stuff like that we really never had
problems with bikers it was Spring
Breakers though I got a lot of videos on
the other hand on my uh I got a lot of
videos of them on my Instagram if you
guys can go on my Instagram me and the
biker bars hanging out with them yeah
because he he used to go to the bike
night in Samford yeah our schedule's
kind of [__] up so they're asking me
where where are you you know that kind
of [__] I had to do some clutch
adjustment on my on one of my bikes and
the one I like to ride down there a lot
but I'm ready to start going back but
thing is we stream well yeah but we can
stream on Thursday nights okay like we
did last night because we streamed last
night instead of Tuesday night maybe
next maybe next Tuesday because Tuesday
night when I came home we were gonna
stream but then I had like a bunch of
freelance work to do and I was like I
really got to get this done so we didn't
really have time so we streamed last
night okay we you know so we can do
Thursday nights maybe yeah
that might be a little bit better yeah
because we did we did do stream eight
lace last night for not long like
probably like an hour and 15 minutes
something like that that was closer to
45 minutes no it was we started at about
quarter to eight and then we stopped at
like right at nine o'clock yeah because
I've had to start getting ready for work
you know yeah we made I think about 60
Gold but which is take home about 20
some
or maybe a little bit more but yeah just
for just like a little bit more than an
hour yeah because and that was mostly
from one per well one person gave us
like a 15 gold tip and then somebody
like went on like paid for a private
yeah it was on for a while and I think
there was a couple other people watching
yeah because you looked up they were
talking to each other in there yeah you
can you can buy it in you can buy in
like for the private ones like exclusive
like I said that's when you pay just for
you and the performers yeah private you
can pay but other people can pay to come
in and watch the [__] too I grabbed the
camera off the [__] thing I'm going
[__]
going point of view and [__] cooking I
had a good time yeah it's fine
according to my buddy Bill who he's been
doing this for a long time he's from
[__] uh he he's uh he owns Quinn Studios
which is a local porn Production Studio
his wife is a hardcore
actress named
Quinn what's her name [__] uh
Amy yeah Amy Quinn with two ants you can
find her on Twitter
and uh they did she does gang bangs and
[__] interracial gangbangs and just
all kinds of [__] crazy [__]
but um she's probably half her income
comes off a stream mate
and uh
bill says it right now because it's
summer it's real slow
he says it's a fraction of what it is so
I showed him our figures and what our
averages were the numbers
and he's like yeah as soon as Summer's
over you're going to be having you know
[__] several hundred dollars a night
you know because there's a lot more
people normally but right now it's going
real slow I mean I was surprised we like
I said we were on for just maybe a
little more than an hour and we had a
lot of people like in and out you know
what I mean and we did end up like a lot
of people did go private yeah they're
just having fun you know jugging around
and some people like I said just talking
we were just talking about regular [__]
it wasn't like you know one guy says
yeah I used to stream and [__] yeah a
guy from Australia I'll help you out
he's over in Australia assistant I know
I can know so we got his contact
but uh that one customer without that
paid all that money was a couple yeah
that was a guy and a girl we've been
getting that I noticed that because I
guess couples look for other couples
yeah because we have gotten
couples a lot of that and one thing that
we get a lot too is like couples that
are both subs
that want us to yell at them yeah and
they want that for free though right
they want us they want us to yell at
them and like make fun of theirs you
don't know if it's if that's in that
situation it might have been somebody
impersonating a couple too on that one
that was a different one yeah that's
right that person didn't pay us but we
had that happen like last time too like
we were always getting like yeah
but because the way we look they they
assume that we're like into a bondage
fetish and BDSM which we know about it
yeah you know we we've been to those
events
we have friends that are more I mean we
do a little bit of that but it's not
like yeah it's not over there it's not
like not like a main thing yeah so they
trying to sell themselves as slaves to
us and [__] and [__] they're like
okay we'll go private they don't want to
go private they want to do this [__] for
free
yeah we have yeah we had some in there
like wanted us to own them yeah and I'm
just you know it's crazy [__]
well like I said you got another fantasy
you gotta watch because you can't I mean
you have to keep people engaged you want
them to stay in your room but it's like
you can't give people too much for free
because people are always trying to like
get [__] they're scamming off you for
nothing and they're in there wasting
your time a lot of their time wasters
and lurkers
people who are just watching they don't
say anything yeah so you got to go in
there and go and address them by name
try to get them to respond if they don't
[__] respond you kick them out you
don't have to block them but you can
kick them out to come back in and they
do it again just keep kicking them out
yeah I mean most people when they come
in will actually just say hi or how are
you or something like give you some
compliments on Italy right so it's like
they'll at least say something or like
interact you know what I mean but some
people like come in and then they'll
just kind of like lurk yeah because you
can see when people come in like they're
yeah they're in there their screen name
comes up but it's like sometimes like
you'll ask them some [__] like hey how
are you what's whatever your screen name
is what state are you in or you know
where are you from or blah blah blah and
it's like sometimes they don't answer
most of the time they do but like yeah
so there's some people in there some
dude it's like a jerk in it for free
just watch staring at you
can't [__] it or anything it's just no I
they're just here like I said I don't
give anything away in the in the public
chat because that's just kind of I I I I
don't really like to do that because
like I said why would anybody pay if
they can try your share for free yeah
technically like I said you can't shoot
tits yeah in the public chat but you
flashed them when they tipped you that's
that's why I did well yeah that's what
you're supposed to do like somebody
flashes you and it's like hey you wanna
you but yeah you can do that yeah but I
don't like just leave them hanging out
because like I said I said some people
on there just like [__] they're naked
the whole time and I'm just like why
would you do that yeah it just kind of
seems counterproductive and the the gay
section is usually dead and the dudes
that are in there [__] don't look so
good
so a lot of times you have gay guys
coming in looking at the couples and
they're [__] start attacking me
asking me to do [__] I was like come on
man [__] I already have warm up here
another me to work you want me to go
solo in front of you just freaking dead
nothing I don't have [__] heart
because you know you're gonna turn it it
ain't gonna work bro you know it's gonna
take now you know how girls feel all the
time because they want you they want you
to rock up put on a whole show for them
and everything in three minutes because
they only want to be on for about three
minutes or pay of 4.99 599 yeah they're
trying to go fast
and like yeah okay dude you got you're
already [__] racked up I mean there's
one there's a thing called physiology
yeah yeah it takes time you know what I
mean well how long it's gonna take and
it says oh at least 15 20 minutes
oh that's too much money I see it
well that's the thing it's like you know
well here's the thing like the internet
is full of porn Okay the internet is
full of porn like that's pre-recorded
videos yeah we got videos on the thing
and well and I'm just saying that it's
like if that's what you want to why you
want three minutes of like some dude
jerk in it and like it's like you can
find video of that yeah yeah like don't
put it don't put a man on the spot like
that yeah like on a [__] live stream
all right maybe that's what they get off
on though yeah maybe because they're
just like we want to see this dude
squirting I just [__] grab that
[__] camera slap my dick on it
right come in and ask me how big it is
and [__] yeah we did yeah
and then they and that was starting to
[__] them she's trying to get me to talk
about my dick for free huh they were
they were like they wanted to send a
picture of theirs yeah we could do a
comparison and then he wanted was he the
same guy that wanted me to like that
wanted me to make fun of it I don't know
I don't remember yeah I don't remember
but there was somebody that wanted to
just [__] crazy [__] you
can't take you can't take everything
they say at face value because they're
[__] with you a lot of times yeah I
know yeah but it's like you know
a lot a surprising amount of people do
want you to make fun of their dicks I've
noticed yeah you're in your mom's
basement man that's a pretty common
thing I guess yeah like telling you how
pathetic it is can I have another drink
yeah
this is I'm only at the bottom of my
first one well that was no like [__]
um
like the second time we streamed it had
dude [__] surreptitiously sent us a
photo of his [__] that's right yeah and
he's asked us to rate it Jenny's rating
it yeah it has to do this [__]
pitiful he said he starts laughing
no see so he got away he got away free
for that yeah most people [__] so if
you could do that you got to pay
attention up 10 bucks right yeah yeah
you can't like I said you can't you
can't do [__] for free but everybody's
trying to get you to do [__] for free
yeah
you know even though like most of the
people that are on there you know their
guests or members or whatever they have
presumably like have an account on there
and have given their credit card number
and everything like that but
you know I get they don't want to pay
for everything and they don't have all
the money but
I mean it is a pay site
so but I guess I can't blame him too
much for trying to like scam and like
get [__] for free but you know what I
mean James says well how big is it well
it's like I didn't really want to say
and I was just kind of like I was kind
of like
um above average that I was like all I
wanted to say
so I was like I don't know I never
measured it well because I said to Tom I
was like well you probably measured it
because I feel like it hasn't happened
most dudes like measured their dicks I
feel like isn't that a thing that most
dudes do
because he said that he measured a long
time ago but
I never measured it personally I never
measured your dick did I who I never
measured your dick uh nothing no no not
that I know unless you did it while I
was sleeping
yeah I measured it while you're sleeping
time
[Laughter]
got dick measurements and meat and [__]
like that it's inconsistent
it's gonna depend on where you're
measuring yeah the top or the bottom
side of it you could cheat you could she
flew into the tip to the bottom side
[__] you know [__] you can get extra
three inches that way
it's not gonna be quite as long because
the the way the angles are and then
another thing is like
your level of arousal the [__] changes
sure [__] there have been times where
I would just [__]
coin nuts man I look down and it's like
God damn that's me it's like sticking
way out there
murder Hornet said Tom has a horse dick
I mean
you know I'm just saying I'm not
I'm not saying anything definitively but
yeah
yeah James says sex work is such a big
industry now it's insane only fans
really kick [__] into high gear and yes
most dudes do see that was I mean you
know
I've known a lot of dudes in my life I
have a couple of Brothers you know what
I mean so
I know how I know how that [__] works
I feel like most of most of my male
friends and everything like that are
like yeah we totally did that [__] it's
just maybe kind of like
I don't know I want to say it's like
girls like measuring their tits but I
don't know if a lot of girls do that I
didn't do that
I had some friends that did that but it
wasn't like Universal whereas I feel
like dudes measuring their dicks is
probably almost Universal
and
[Laughter]
Yeah we actually tried to get on only
fans but it's a pool hall it's a pain in
the ass they really don't
um after a while I just gave up and
because I was just kind of like they
always kept coming up with some excuse
It's like oh you don't have enough
social media presence or you don't you
know at least as far as like the the
porny [__] goes because we originally
just started out so honestly I was just
like why don't we just try again later
and not even worry about it right now so
Tom got a account on fansley and I
applied for fansley but they take a
really long time so I haven't heard back
from them yet but fansley is good
because we'll be able to put up the
videos that we made and we can tag each
other and we can sell them because I
can't sell videos with both of us on
streamate just me
because that's the rules
so like I said we're still kind of
learning the ropes I'm kind of hoping
that that guy we talked to on stream 8
last night was legit because he said
like I said he was from Australia and he
said that he used to do streamate also
um and he really missed it
and he was like um
he's like oh I have a Snapchat
um so he told me to start a Snapchat and
we could like talk over there and he's
like I can like tell you how all of it
works and everything like that because
like I said we're kind of figuring it
out but
you know it's a lot to take in and
there's like other formats too that for
selling videos or I think we're probably
just for streaming just stick with
stream eight because that seems like the
biggest one other than ChatterBait and
I'm not going on that channel so um it's
like [__] in the Roman Coliseum
that's what I mean I don't really like
that anymore even though I'm I'm gonna
say like I said I'm not I'm not bothered
it doesn't really bother me
um it's a strange experience it is a
little bit but it's like it wasn't as
weird as I thought it would be it's
because you're at home
yeah so it's and like I said it's not
that weird because we're just basically
doing [__] we mostly be doing anyway
yeah it's just you have to kind of like
you know play to the camera and you have
to make sure that the camera you know
can see what's going on and [__] like I
think when me man is the time limits
these dudes are [__] asking for
instance if you [__] hop up and do
some [__] performance and [__]
[__] you know in three minutes a girl
can fake it they got a huge advantage
but dude it takes you about [__] five
ten minutes to get [__] revved up
just so okay I can do it now I'm gonna
do it it's gonna take some foreplay
these dudes don't have time for that
they want they don't have the time they
have time they don't have the money for
that yeah so because
really if
really [__] you know and you know
it's not just me other dudes have
[__] said the same thing really if
you want if they want to see sex it had
to be during a gold show
yeah
right you know what I mean where it's
gonna happen in 30 minutes from now and
expecting it's gonna cost [__] 400
gold we're gonna have 10 guys watching
it or whatever
you could do it that way but these
little [__] five minute things and
three minute things all night how are
you gonna keep up with that all [__]
night no man could yeah
and then in dude's like yeah I want to
get a [__] shot at the end how how many
day you know what I mean right [__]
20 of them a day it ain't gonna happen
yeah now there's some drugs that you
could take
they're talking about dick size and how
aroused you are at the time [__] and
uh [__] murder harness saying I have
a horse dick I don't have a horse dick
it's big though
um
five six
178 pounds
about 13 body fat I'm about seven inches
all right but on a frame as short as
mine it looks bigger than it is
although I like how humble you are about
it yeah it's mostly optical illusion
that's an optical
I don't know about that but okay
although that might be bullshitting that
with that because all my exes says no
you're big
yeah the latest
you're definitely larger than average
yeah okay much larger than average
my dad was even bigger
that's weird Tom yeah
that's a weird thing to say no I know
we'll be pissing up
I heard that [__] from my mom and dad
and his friends and [__] even
because it says genetic it's definitely
genetic
um
but uh what was it gonna say about
about that [__] um
it's just
oh I was gonna say with the drugs yeah
yeah
Viagra
that's this just in Cialis that's some
just some civilian [__] in the porn
industry [__] that's just all guys
are on that okay yeah it's like the
Baseline yeah you have to have that it
doesn't matter how old you are because
just what happens on set and [__] how
long because you just have to keep going
yeah it takes a little hours and hours
and hours yeah you're seeing you're
seeing a 15-minute scene but that was
actually done in about two or three
hours yeah
it's been edited to gather into a
15-minute scene
and through with Viagra you you look
different man it's like the difference
between natural titties and implants you
get you get bigger
uh it's because you're [__]
blood vessels are [__] Contracting
like crazy I guess and [__] you just
[__]
the quality is good
but that's amateur [__] they got
something that's even [__] more
hardcore called trimix
and try mix is something that you inject
into it right into yourself and it's
straight guys use it straight porn guys
use it to do gay porn
right all right
[__]
my buddy who I was buying my muscle
buddy who was buying steroids from was
doing that to to do gay porn
to beat up and [__] twinks on camera
try mix the problem with trimix is that
it puts builds up over time builds up
scar tissue in there from the injections
because it's it's kind of addictive yeah
once a guy does that
you're gonna kind of want to fall back
on that
because it's like an easy way out right
you know well it's just like anything
it's like anywhere else it starts to
become kind of psychologically dependent
and you get [__] huge on that [__]
you know bigger than [__] Viagra
so if Viagra is kind of like a girl get
getting some [__]
Double D implants try mixes like they're
[__]
[__] Triple G yeah plants you know
what I mean this [__] big [__]
it's like that
and uh
it of course it removes all [__]
performance anxiety
you don't care now you can do anything
you're not worried about it like I can
Hammer nails with this [__] yeah
like a [__] a car just like that guy on
My Strange Addiction
[__] a skyscraper with this
sorry I just had a really funny mental
image yeah
humping this guy's crazy yeah the
problem though is it builds up scar
tissue in there and then you gotta have
some antidotes on hand and see in case
something goes wrong because it's got a
way to counteract that [__]
and he was telling me that [__] that
some of those dudes are so good at it
they got medical kits to where if the
shit's going on too long and then they
say [__] it's Aiken they'll actually
stick if [__]
pretty large gauge needle into
themselves to train the blood out of it
to get the [__] to get the inflation
to come not really the kind of life you
want Tom
I don't know
these are stunt [__] man they're trying
to do some [__] on film that [__] if
they don't really want to do don't mess
I'm just gonna use my mind it's nice the
way it is
[Laughter]
a big dick but having big nuts make your
dick makes your dick look smaller yes
yeah go on go on gear
because your nuts will get smaller yeah
um and what's funny is like people are
thinking like well you it's not just
really it's not the testes inside the
bed the bag itself gets smaller yeah
it'll kind of go back to what it was
when you were like
a teenager
because when you get older it [__]
that [__] [__] come out and look at a
damn turkey neck
drink your dick but that's because of
the way your hormones are set up but if
you you know
yeah so I'm looking good right now looks
real good looks good on camera you can
see it on camera
I got pictures of it
now whole videos
still need to do some solo videos yeah
yeah I'll do something put on your
family yeah I keep hoping every day yeah
she's [__] I'm at work and I'm just
like I keep hoping every time he every
time he messages me I'm like is this the
day oh yeah
about motorcycles and [__] worry
about other [__] and I had to do all
this lawn work I had I mowed today you'd
notice and I Edge to the other day
oh [__] yeah I got a edger okay yeah I
know yeah I bought Andrew on the Lowe's
card
because because the uh HOA [__]
complained
I thought that the HOA at this place
weren't going to be as bad as the HOA at
the old place but
well they're right though because I went
out and looked at everybody else's
engine and everybody else was edged
we've been here for a year and they
haven't complained
okay so they let us slap they let us
slide for a long time because we didn't
even have an edger until no I got that
electric edger got uh was it what's that
[__] called with the k
um Cobalt oh they're blue I wouldn't
have guessed that I like those Cobalt
Electric Tools got electric e weed eater
and an electric [__] um chainsaw
because when I cut those branches down
with and uh now I got an electric edger
I sound like a [__] Suburban old man
I was just gonna say yeah and I got a
ride on lawnmower that [__] he does have
a running line yeah I got that too well
you kind of have to have one because I
mean it's like an acre yeah it's massive
yeah
I mean if you were just mowing that with
the phone Golf Course Golf Course out
there yeah this is a golf course that's
one of the nice things about this
neighborhood as opposed to the old like
I like I liked our old neighborhood too
but the houses were kind of close
together yeah like here the houses are
really far apart like most people have
half acre to an acre of land so I mean
there's houses but they're way farther
apart and in Florida if you have an acre
you can shoot on it
the thing is I'm 0.9 Acres so I can't
set it and there's there's houses all
over so I can't I can't go out there and
zero I just want a place where I can
zero AR-15 there's got to be somewhere
around here because somebody I hear them
shoot because I can hear it
I can hear it
um Mackie Mac says I just drink high
caffeine drinks and I get it going must
be the caffeine oh maybe
um
murder Hornet says I take 200 milligram
Viagra [__] stays hard after you blow
your wad yeah Victor says first get a
bee to sting your dick it'll make it
bigger and it's organic
murder Hornets
murder Hornets he he lives on the
Mexican border he's an american guy
lives on a Mexican board Mexican
girlfriend and [__] he'll go down there
and [__] uh he'll go down to the
pharmacy
I got him on test he started [__]
trimming up man he's looking really good
and his Mexican girlfriend started
[__] telling me he started looking
like a skinny junkie and I said dude you
look [__] great what are you talking
about man if I can go back on test man
well my girlfriend says I look like a
junk it's dude man's girlfriend's fat
she's Mexican of course she's gonna say
you she's eating on a diet of tortillas
man you're making her feel bad yeah
you're making her feel bad man go back
on test man you were you were looking
good and then go lift some weights man
yeah build some Mass up so then he goes
down to the brothel in Mexico it has me
and he he's streaming this [__] through
his phone has me picked the girl out
I hate that that's that's that's a
brother there yeah that's a real friend
see this is what he said like a real
friend we'll be sitting there we'll be
sitting there out we'll be sitting there
into bed and I'll be like watching like
I don't know Rift tracks or some [__]
like that and he's over there on his
tablet and he's like yeah murder Hornets
he wants me to like pick a hooker
[Laughter]
those girls are cute too okay those
girls are cute
Mackie Mac also says women no need for a
sex toy they just have to sit on a
washing machine that does the job
you know what it's it's funny because I
had always heard that
like um it was kind of like it almost
seemed like it was a sitcom joke or like
it was like in movies and stuff it's
like oh he's just gonna go sit on the
washing machine or leave against the
washing machine or something like that
which
I don't know I guess that would be
enjoyable but I don't
I don't know I don't see how it's maybe
like people are more sensitive than me
but
I'm just kind of like yeah it'd probably
be kind of nice but
I don't know if just sitting on a
washing machine went too much of
anything you know what I'm saying
you know what I'm saying I I kind of
need a little bit more than that
densely link
um actually I don't know what what is
Tom's I'm gonna have to ask him I can't
remember because we have like like I
said we have a Twitter we have a
streamate and we have like different
names for all of that and I don't
remember what he used for the fansley I
don't even remember what I used for the
fans League because it was like a week
or two ago that I
registered for it and I can't even
remember what [__] name I used we've
been using like variations of our names
like with 13 at the end the problem with
streammate though arose because I wanted
to call it
um 13 can that was like what the um logo
that I made and everything like that and
they were like yeah you can't have any
name that has a number in it that's
under 18 because they don't want to
encourage you know pedos
so um so I had to change it
there's all these different [__]
rules on every goddamn Apple they're
yeah they're like real sensitive about
that because I'm sitting there you know
like I didn't even think of why at the
time that I was like oh yeah duh gotta
have a dirty mind yeah
um
we got to look at uh
clips for sale in minivids yeah those
lots of next stuff we gotta get gotta
get because we have material we can sell
under right now yeah because like I said
we have a bunch of videos that we
actually can't sell on streamate because
he's mm yeah and like streamate they
won't even let me put up one with his
voice in it yeah like even if his face
is in it he's not in it and there's some
things that we filmed where my hand has
to come in to move a camera because
there's multiple cameras going on there
and my hand comes in did you did you
have to zoom in yeah so my hand couldn't
would I mean just in case just because
I'm always kind of like because the one
video that I did with the weird like
monster dicks the weird dildos like I
did that and it's like you weren't even
in it because you were filming it yeah
but you talked to me a couple of times
and like I talked to you a couple times
so your voice was in it and it's like so
they wouldn't let me it was just his
voice no face no hand no nothing this is
what she's talking about and they
wouldn't let me click it down
extraterrestrial yeah yeah
and then that one that [__] right there
man that [__] still hurts
that's like it looks cool dragon it
looks cool though like I said I call
that my yeah love crafty face Dragon
tentacle like I said they have one on I
think it's on Amazon actually that's
kind of like that but it's like way more
like a tentacle like it's longer and
it's like more tapered at the end and I
was like I kind of want that because
it's cool looking but it's like I don't
know if I'd ever actually use it for its
intended purpose it's [__]
what you doing Pokey James says bro
those vids I need yeah but yeah so I did
one like that and like I had to go
through and like edit out every single
they finally did accept it they finally
let me if you go on stream mate and look
at Jen tomcam
in the couple section you have to become
a member you just give them your credit
card information
I did it myself when I scouted that
scouted it out
so they're good with uh with your
information you know they're safe if you
go to our profile in there
um you'll find videos that are already
for sale
how many of them are up there I think
there is like seven or eight of them
seven or eight yeah and they range in
prices from like a couple bucks to like
probably 15 probably 10. yeah I think
the most expensive one is maybe 14. 14
or 12.98 it depends on what's in it how
long it is yeah it's just but they're
all solo gen videos yeah because they
wouldn't let me upload like I said we we
got other shits a lot better than that
we filmed some stuff yeah because we
didn't know we didn't we didn't know
that we could sell it in other places we
didn't know where we could sell right I
didn't know that streammate wasn't gonna
let me yeah like even with your [__]
voice in it it makes no sense because
I've approved to stream there so I had
to edit out like everywhere that you
talked ridiculous like in that so we got
to keep all those edits straight
you got all the edits straight that way
on other platforms more or less well
what I usually do is if I do an edit
yeah I'll usually Call It Whatever the
title of the video is and then I'll put
streamate in big letters that last one
that you did has to be re-edited with
that other stuff put back into it we
have all that right
yeah okay as long as you got the wrong
like I said I keep everything and like I
said I was gonna show you how to use the
editing song yeah so if you ever want to
come in here and edit something or if
you make a video right and you want to
edit it it's not hard to use like it's
kind of tedious but it's pretty easy
it's pretty user friendly yeah like the
one that I use
so
I mean you might you might get a lot out
of that like if you you know because
you'll be able to like do your own [__]
too yeah
um I can't believe that fansley hasn't
[__] approved you yet yeah I'll have
to send him a message tomorrow or
something and say hi yeah it took me a
couple weeks
Victor said my old co-worker who had a
crush on hasn't only fans I subscribe to
it he's hot as [__]
we'll get in there one of these days a
lot of male profiles
uh I scout out the competition to see
how I'm gonna Stack Up and how it fit in
in with uh the male competition
most of those dudes are dogs
it's always kind of like some kind of
extreme it's it's either some dude it's
just like man
[__] you know standards must be low
around here
or some dude you just can't believe that
[__] actually exists I mean just
jacked just [__]
I'd still be in the top 15 though based
on what I'm saying yeah easily
um problem with it is that you know it's
everything's about numbers and marketing
uh there's
females do not buy porn they just don't
they'll watch it but they won't buy it
yeah not paying for that [__] so
if you're a straight guy you have to
make products that gay guys will buy
um
and I'm not going to be like [__] uh
[__] higher my muscle buddies to come
over here and [__] slam it on me and
[__]
although I would love to see that
I have seen some there's a couple
Russian guys out there that I respect
their [__] game all right
I could tell that whoever's behind that
camera filming is his girlfriend okay
and he's going through a virtual date
he's meeting you at the mall and takes
you back to his place and [__] you on
the first date he's doing all the he's
got the stick Russian accent he's using
[__] American gay slang I'm going
bareback in you I'm breeding you like
he's just [__] hilarious and it's
just him alone you know
he's got sex toys and [__]
he's got this [__] man ass
rubber man
those are so weird yeah I used to sell
those on Amazon would have this [__]
underneath his bed or something
but he talks mad game man and he [__]
his profiles are there that says that he
is so Alpha he's here to turn straight
men into straight up beta [__] I mean
it just sounds like you yeah and I'm
going like [__] yeah dude exactly
he's PR just man [__] got
serious mouth game on him
[__] respect he's just talking mad
[__]
that's really fun yeah it's funny
murderheart said Tom just whack off case
will like it
if you look at what though don't
overthink it though if you look at what
those dudes make
it's just video after video if after
video some naked [__] on his
back [__] jerking it it's the same
video over and over again there's no
personality and those dudes those dudes
are all losers
they can't even come up with a [__]
story
or you know I mean and there's no
personality in any of that [__]
and it's like the same video over and
over again
I would expect more for gays I thought
gays would be all [__] um I thought
gays would be all [__] artistic about
it and come up with some good ideas and
costumes and [__] no
is take off all their clothes hairy
[__] laying there belly and
[__]
no Style
terrible
it's [__] terrible terrible and the
dudes that we're doing best dudes that
stood out they're [__] getting all
the action those are straight dudes
well like I said you really have to I
mean the market is saturated and so you
really have to like have some kind of
angle yeah
you know because there's a lot of people
doing right
said just [__] a flesh Jack while Jenny
slaps Tom with a dildo
we could we could do a video like that
that'd be super fun we got all that yeah
we get we got all that Jenny [__] hit
me in a bag of head
trying to concentrate
oh my God we need to deal see there's a
you see this a lot of the edits of the
[__] that me and Jen make there's a lot
of humor in it
[Music]
I still laugh when I see that
damn
well you always kind of yeah yeah it
depends on what we were doing you always
kind of made me laugh like when you do
that kind of like like you just can't
like you just can't even can't take it
you can't that's like really really
funny
yeah uh James says cosplay is another
one that's pretty prevalent too yeah
yeah I mean seriously well see I gotta
bang costumes see that's what yeah
that's what he was talking to me about
like military [__] yeah see you should
totally like it'd be all hyper masculine
well just do like I said do you need to
find something that you like to do that
is that it's like unique to you you know
what I mean because it's like don't do
the same [__] other people yeah don't do
that because it's like you're not gonna
stand out you're just gonna be doing the
same [__] everybody else is doing we see
we I came up with a good one just while
we were [__] uh talking I think last
week it says you're going to be the
you're you're going to get the camera
and we're gonna go to some dessert Mall
bathroom and I want to be up there
taking a leak at the urinal and you walk
in and I'm gonna pretend like you're
some dude I said dude what the [__] you
doing in here
and then then you go to the urinals he's
gonna make me snap a [__] like you can
never [__] stand up
[__] down when you come in sit down and
make them [__] make him sit down and
piss
you know what I mean
yeah he said I don't ever want to catch
you in here like this I won't ever cut
you in the men's restroom again
Victor says did we ever start that
GoFundMe so Tom can get pegged
our friends Dimitri would probably give
a lot of money to that because he always
brings that out he'd want to copy the
video aren't you oh yeah he played the
[__] at the club he probably would like
on the big screens and stuff that sounds
like some [__] he would do you have this
[__] [__] I need these [__] Pipers
you get that [__] [__] mixed in with
all the [__] and I'd be like yeah
it's just me [__] just lay it out
being pegged by Jenny
ridiculous now one thing that we did do
on the show well that we attempted to do
was one of the people that was paying
for the private
they wanted to know
this is like these shows are like so TMI
but I don't care
so he wanted to know if I'd ever [__]
two guys at once yeah and uh Tom was
like not that I know of and I was like
not that I know of unless I was passed
out or something not that I remember
I mean I've been pretty drunk before but
I don't know he was laughing at her
reactions though yeah yeah but so Tom
was like well let's try and put two of
these dildos in here at the same time
well no he said that well you've
suggested that okay she's trying to get
both of them in there try to get both of
them in there so we did try to get both
of them like two yeah it didn't work no
it didn't work no but I mean kinda but
not nah and we even like took two of the
like more reasonable size ones yeah it
wasn't like because I have that one
that's like a [__] it's like it's
like this big around
I was like yeah if we're not doing that
but I was like we'll get some of the
smaller ones and we'll see yeah I was
like that's not two of those aren't
going in there obviously
Avalanche seriously though well
so we have like all of them because they
all have like um
suction cups on the bottom so we have
all of them like on a little shelf over
there
and that clear one that clear one like
falls off all the time so I'll be like
in here working or whatever and then all
of a sudden I hear and I'm like what the
[__] was that it's like [__] ghosts
yeah just that clear dildo fell off
murder harnesses
yeah and I think that that's good
because I mean like I said I don't know
if we've
found our groove with the live streaming
yeah because we haven't done it that
many times
um there's different styles and
techniques you can use right it's like
being in the carnival there's a bunch of
different angles you can play yeah and
um
gotta find it gotta find something that
[__] works for us that the system you
know and talking to Bill Bill gave me a
bunch of ideas
I'm gonna get into them
yeah like I said it's good that you're
friends with that guy yeah he's big into
the [__]
he still wants me to come [__] shoot
with him because he's got all kind of
information he's like man [__] [__]
if I ever need help on a shoot you come
over and [__] you know and I'll give
you free training and I said all right
he's not gonna pay me but just go on the
porn shoot [__] watch these girls get
[__] torn through by a whole train of
dudes
that's this whole thing man it's
probably his wife yeah yeah
which yeah like I said that's kind of
takes a special kind of it takes a
special kind of what's funny is that
they're very normal
well yeah like a lot but most people are
normal like you know like people that
are in your freaky [__] or it's most of
them are normal yeah they're very normal
like everybody's normal it's fine I'm
watching this [__] and I'm like going
man huh
I you know I wouldn't [__] want my
girlfriend or even wife to go some [__]
like that oh no no she's fine you know
it's just like
don't take any this seriously it's it's
it's straight business yeah I get that
they don't take anything but like I said
I didn't even happen and I mean like I
said we kind of talked about this though
but I was just kind of like I don't know
I still have a kind of thing where
I don't know I just don't really like
the idea of it I'm not bothered by being
in my house and like doing it on video
or you know doing a live stream or
something like that because nobody's
here yeah you know what I mean I'm just
in my house and it's just you and yeah
so it's like I don't really care about
that but it's just kind of like I don't
I don't like the idea of like [__] a
bunch of windows
I was like did she get anything out of
that you think and she's like no
no well yeah I would imagine not just
trying to get through it it's just like
any of making any other kind of movie
yeah it's not like I said the women have
it easy it's the guys that have it hard
because they have to [__] perform and
then they have to have a finish you know
they have to [__] be able to bust a
nut and they're in a crowded room with a
bunch of people
uh but they get used to it yeah but it
says a lot of times you gotta fake the
finishes or the endings were tacked on
later
they were shot under two different
two different
um circumstances in other words all of a
sudden you know when a guy gets ready to
do to do the [__] money shot
the camera angle changes well that might
have not been that wasn't the exact same
time right
it was done with maybe only a couple
people around
depends
yeah it will it's just like anything
else it's like they're just trying to
make the final product so however they
can manage that yeah some of it's just
kind of pasted and taped together like I
said a live stream is a little bit
different because you don't really have
the luxury of it is or doing several
takes or anything like that or it's like
oh hey I'll go take a break and come
back in 40 minutes or yeah or time their
[__] putting you on a time
limit
but like I said the thing about it for
the performance anxiety [__] is
going to try to give you [__] four
minutes to do all this [__] and you're
like dude well like I said you have to
think too that you can't get to you
can't like overthink it because you
don't have to do anything that you do
yeah you can't let them do you yeah
um you know what I mean because look
there's like millions of other people
there's like tons of other porn like
they could go look at other porn like
it's not a big thing they probably
weren't gonna pay anyway so it's just
kind of like don't worry too much about
that
you know
I think that I don't know like I'm
usually the overthinker but
I I don't really overthink it
was going to Z show those shows sound
Next Level which I don't know what shows
you're talking about
well like the ones on the ones on
streammate that we do yeah yeah like I
said we've only done a few I think we've
only done four at this point
no actually if you're if you're there
when it shit's going down it's
very basic
because those dudes don't last long man
well yes and like I said most of them
want like pretty basic stuff it's just
kind of like so nobody wants anything
super complicated like I said the
weirdest thing it's not even weird but
it's like the weirdest thing was like
well they wanted you to like smack me in
the face yeah Snapper and face which way
did we did that yeah we did that yeah
yeah just I would just slap her in your
face as hard as he wanted me to
well yeah you better it was saying nine
out of ten I said dude [__] night
I didn't knock her out [__] tend to
kill her
yeah yeah you don't want to do it well
just slap her as hard as you feel
comfortable with it's not gonna put your
bruises are
you know so I had I was popping my hand
I I kind of cupped my hand so I'd make a
nice pop yeah you wanna you just mostly
want the sound just to get the sound
yeah like I said it's you know it like
kind of It kind of stings but it didn't
like linger you know so you didn't like
it that hard yeah John Garner said
someone a woman said to me I can't
imagine how someone could just have sex
with a complete stranger I said it must
be analogous to soldiering a like
killing someone you never even met yeah
maybe like I said I'm not a big fan of
like I said I've I don't know if I've
like would say that I've [__] a random
person but it's like I have
you know had sex with somebody that I
just met yeah like that night like a one
night stand type situation a little bit
I've done that yeah I've done that a
couple times but it's like I hung out
with them for like hours beforehand
before it so it wasn't just like so I
knew who they were so I was like oh this
person's okay or whatever but it's like
and I haven't done that that much really
yeah so
but yeah it's just it doesn't really
appeal to me
um just that idea of and like I said no
shade on people that do like doing it
like because some people do like doing
porn like some women do like doing porn
and it's like that it doesn't bother
them but I don't know I just I don't
really like the idea of it because I'm
like look but I don't know you you know
yeah I don't know
porn's artificial
that's another thing yeah it's very
artificial so it's not even like and and
doing porn is like not really like yeah
you're having sex with that person but
it's not really the same as I'm saying
having sex with them like in private you
know what I mean that's completely
different kind of like not real real sex
it's a performance yeah like it is but
it's not other stuff right where if
you're worried about well hope the
[__] audio is picking this up I hope
the camera's good wonder how this is
gonna work out and edit okay the whole
thing's pretty much reserved rehearsed
we're gonna do this this this and this
and this we're going to try to get this
we're gonna try to get this done it's
got to be about 15 minutes long
so it's kind of an artificial the thing
is though is that [__] video working
on videos a lot easier than live
um
the
evidently according to we've never done
this we're not going to do this but
according
to people in the industry in this
General Industry the easiest is [__]
escorting because it's the most normal
because it's just one person dealing
with another person there's plenty of
time but like I said that's not good
that's not normal for me though because
it's like I don't really like
interacting with other other people what
I meant in terms of the sex yeah sex
feels more normal more like a date
yeah because that's kind of the way it
sounds that's the way it kind of is so
uh
but uh video's a lot easier than stream
yeah I mean it's still work but we have
fun doing that yeah and it's a lot less
pressure a lot less pressure I mean I
like doing the live streams they're fun
yeah you know what's gonna happen
yeah and you never know what people are
going to come in and ask for which is
always kind of interesting
um but yeah I mean there is like a
little bit of but you know that's why we
drank on the show
because after a drink I'm just kind of
like ah who gives a [__] whatever yeah
we'll we'll do whatever and like I said
you don't have to do anything that you
don't want to do like people can come in
and ask for [__] and it's like you're
like no I don't want to do that that's
all then they can just go someplace else
and say you you don't have to feel like
obligated some of them seem to be asking
just to get a rise out of you too a
certain [__] that's what I'm saying and
like say yeah and sometimes people are
like they're asking for [__] but you
know they're not gonna pay I'm gonna pay
for it so it's just kind of like so
don't you know you don't get too hung up
about it because it's like most like 90
of the people aren't gonna pay anyways
so it's just kind of like like you said
they're just trying to get a rise out of
you or they're trying to I don't know
what they're trying to do but they're
just trying to come in being like he
goes escorting a sketch yeah sketchy
it's like I said it's very dangerous
yeah escorting is hooking I mean [__] we
just did a show like on Wednesday about
the Long Island series serial killer and
that was the whole thing about those
poor girls that were doing escorting on
Craigslist and like ended up meeting
this [__] who [__] murdered
him yeah who would have passed most
professional screenings that's what's
scary about yeah he'd have gone through
because most most Pros
want references from other girls before
they'll do work yeah it's like is this
dude normal like yeah and this dude
would have had and and they they like
them middle age plus when she passed
that
and they like them married
and he would have passed all that he
would he would have gotten through say
ayla's [__] system because that dude
was a regular
yeah he was a regular with a bunch of
other girls that he didn't do anything
too it's just certain ones he killed
so he knew their system right he knew
their system
and that's what that's what's scary
about it and like I said it's good that
they have that system and like 99 of the
time I'm sure that that works but always
gonna be somebody that's gonna
circumvent
he actually would have gone through the
acid test is that that's where
you're trying to do business with the
escort
often maybe like Tris dot link or
something
she wants a reference and the reference
you give is your wife
so she gets FaceTime with the wife oh
yeah hey because they usually meet them
FaceTime yeah
and like oh no don't worry honey he's
gonna he's okay you know
that dude would have passed that test
yeah because you know probably would
have said yeah he's okay although I just
heard today that she had filed for a
divorce yeah when today oh today well
yeah well today or yesterday back in his
hooking days if she was hip she would
have [__] referenced it for him
probably because a lot of people you
know [__] some of these girls will
tell you that like one third of the
[__] references and new clients that
comes in is the wife that's the
reference
[Laughter]
which is kind of sad but well I mean
there's no I think think of people that
we know that that that that would work
fetish couples that we know
yeah I mean I get it well I get it that
there's like other situations where it's
like they don't want to get divorced for
various reasons
um the wife doesn't really not
interested anymore and the guy when she
just wants to have fun he's not going
anywhere
yeah yeah it's just entertainment
so uh it's okay honey he's
fat and these are senior citizens
I mean when you think most of the time
you think about it yeah they're over 65
for a lot of
or at least Alice was
she likes them over 65.
just less trouble
well and if he was old enough you knew
you could probably [__] take him if
you had
there you go grandpa I think it was just
more of the I'll pull your [__] fake
teeth yeah they were your dentures
most of those escorts are Fool's Gold
if evidently according to [__] uh was
his name is Sterling Cooper and he was a
he was a male Elite escort
he would escort
Rich Chinese women mostly he knew a lot
of the female escorts and they were his
clients a lot of times these female
escorts don't have boyfriends or
whatever so they'll hire a male escort
to be a boyfriend on a night off type of
deal and he said a lot of them were
Fool's Gold they looked good but they
just weren't any good
you know
just because she's available doesn't
mean she's any good
well that's kind of true of everything
you know I mean it's just like any other
way any other woman you know and the
client the clientele that the clientele
she's dealing with are [__] senior
citizens they were probably happy
they're just happy that there's a woman
they're happy that there's like a
younger one yeah yeah so everything has
to be for the wrinkled old exactly
everything has to be looking under in
the proper perspective
I'm not [__] on old dudes those old
dudes I'm just saying this you know well
some will do different
a lot of that escorting is [__] um uh
like social work
[__] just want [__] lonely
[__]
yeah I kind of some chick to go on the
yacht with them I kind of feel like
that's a lot of the situations it's
probably like 20 sex and 80 other [__]
like companionship and talking and [__]
like that because they're just lonely
you know
laughs
James says how those dudes never got
ganked by the Pips is dumbfounding don't
they follow to make sure the dude don't
do anything well see that's what um
that's what I kind of wonder about what
happened because like I said we did a
show in one day about Long Island serial
killer
and even though Shannon Gilbert you know
they think that she wasn't murdered I
don't know if I entirely believe that or
not but they think that maybe she wasn't
involved but she did have
someone driving her to build and like
most escorts do I feel like it's usually
their boyfriend or you know like a male
friend or something and we'll usually
drive them to their appointments and
we'll wait for them like just in case
like some [__] goes sideways because it
happens uh a lot so you really have to
have somebody watching your back but I
don't know like I think what ended up
happening in that situation was that she
um ended up
you know going in the dude's house and
then she kind of freaked out and then
she and for whatever reason I don't know
if it was a legit reason for her to
freak out or you know according to them
it's like oh maybe she was on drugs or
something and she was overreacting yeah
I don't know I think maybe there was
something that um obviously caused her
to react that
stridently I guess
um so she like ran out the [__] house
and I think after a while like he
couldn't find her and so he was just
like [__] I'm going home I think
that's what happened
but they so most of them do like have
somebody
looking out for them because most of
them that have been doing it for a while
do know that that's very dangerous
thing to be doing
escorting oh it is very dangerous thing
to be doing like I understand you can
make a lot of money doing that but
yeah you end up over in Dubai you never
know what's gonna happen like I said
yeah right the whole [__] time like
everything I have too and it's just kind
of look I I [__] write about True
Crime all the time and I'm just like
that's a that's a good way to like end
up two
girls who are no porn stars here get
called off to into Dubai to go on some
guy's yacht
and they go to the yard it's gorgeous
you know what I mean it's like a [__]
floating apartment and then all of a
sudden 30 dudes show up all his friends
you know what I mean and they they're
gonna get paid but they got to work for
all these dudes and then the [__] the
the billing starts to become very
[__] vague about who owns what and
then they start [__] like escalating
kind of like [__] the degradation you
know kind of misogyny angle on these
girls and they're outnumbered like
[__] 15 to one right yeah they can't
do anything right so they're out on a
yeah and they're like this isn't exactly
what we so they come back but you know
they knew what they were getting into I
mean they [__] go to Dubai so yeah
they went there with
not a whole lot of money and came out
with [__] 30 grand but their dignity
was not intact you know what I mean
that's what I mean it's just not worth
it to me because it's just like you know
that they're gonna try to get over like
that yeah I'm gonna try to get over on
your ass you know they're always going
to show oh it'll be fine we'll do this
on the other thing and then you get
there and it's just like there's all
these other things you have to do and
it's just like I'm just it's not worth
it it's not [__] worth it all the
[__] that you'd have to go through
and you know what those types of dudes
are like it's like they have the money
they and they want to pay to essentially
like you said degrade you yeah and it's
like I'm just not down with that I'm not
down with that well it's not always the
deal but that particular story was like
that yeah
um other ones that I've heard were uh
from high-end
girls who were basically like uh
millionaire
girlfriends and they'll
be on a yacht for about a month with
some dude
and uh
dudes in bed by nine o'clock every night
and she's mostly watching Netflix and uh
he's in his [__] late 60s early 70s
there's not much to the dude and really
the
that the main challenge is to uh pretend
that this dude is interesting
when to do this see I have a hard time
with that kind of stuff too that's
exhausting yeah
even that wouldn't be worth it yeah like
other than like all the degrading sex
stuff which would probably be bad enough
but it's just like having to put up with
this dude for like a long time or
pretend oh my gosh wow that's awesome
like what oh my God that was like I'm
just like please I'm gonna jump off this
[__] ship yeah he's in his 60s I
would probably jump off the ship and
he's uh you know I just can't do it rich
kid silver spoon
he's got power and monies [__] big
businesses
but the thing is a lot of Rich guys
don't have any game you know a lot of
what would they need game for they got
money they got money they don't need
they don't need gas they can buy
whatever they want and uh they just try
to be as interesting as possible like
they're Tony Stark but they're not
you know that's not the way they really
are when you meet them and [__] uh
they're not
impressive really as men they haven't
really what make what gives good
character to anybody it doesn't matter
if you ask me just man or woman is
suffering
anybody who suffered and then triumphed
through it they'd come out stronger
and a lot of people in the elite classes
never suffer it's it's easy and they'll
suffer losses like they might lose money
that's not the same but they still got
the money right it's not it's not like
they lost everything or living in their
[__] car behind the dumpster it's not
like they end up with a maximum security
prison fight for their life for several
years and get out or they [__] go to
war kill some dudes and had half their
[__] body blown off you know what I
mean to come back to their part cyborg
now you know what I mean it's not it's
not the same [__] deal you know
and I'm not saying that everybody has to
suffer to have character they don't but
it does it helps it does help like if
you had to if you had everything handed
to you uh if you had money growing up if
you had like you never really had to
work for anything you may think that you
had to yeah but you didn't because you
had like a lot of advantages that the
rest of us did not have yeah well you
just look at Hunter Biden okay
[__] a rich dude never had any
problems and his only problem is himself
is [__] he's a crackhead with [__]
rotten teeth damn near unlimited money
and [__] [__] hookers imagine you
got to work with that [__] with
this rotten ass Meth mouth
you know I mean I grew up in Daytona I
know all about that
there's a lot of people have that yeah
he's sitting there [__] breaking off
[__] ten thousand twenty thousand and
you just got to put up with this [__]
Meth mouth [__]
you know that'd be kind of degrading to
me that you got to deal with this
[__] and he's cat and you're
kind of addicted to this money you know
what I mean that's a lot of money but
it's not a lot of money to him
see
it's all which is crazy because [__]
twenty thousand dollars I could live a
[__] year on that yeah that but that
would be like somebody hand you know to
him that's like 10 bucks
so this is this is how bizarre it is he
sees you as a cheap [__]
given that [__] 10 20 bucks
where was this
that's what would suck about that
situation Mackie Mac says escorting is
risky there were tons of male escorts uh
doing porn dating gay rich guys some
even blackmail them some clients get
murdered uh gay porn stars arrested on
YouTube it's crazy yeah and then the
Matthew Mac said that Nike Mac you gay
Mac and Mac do you know the scene or
something where do you hear this well no
it's pretty common okay you know what I
mean okay pretty common knowledge yeah
and then James said they got money they
can buy whatever they want like [__]
Epstein yeah yeah
and those dudes are there's lots of them
well that's the thing it's like and
especially like I said if you grew up
with money so you never knew what it was
like
to not have it or to like have to
struggle or to have to work yeah for
money they see you they see people like
us as sub-human
you know and it's so everything was easy
for them but the weird thing about it is
that they don't I guess because they
don't have any frame of reference so
they would always think oh well I had to
struggle I did this that and the other
thing and everybody's just like that's
not a struggling right but right because
but they don't know any different
because they never really had to so they
don't like know what that's like
you know what I mean like I said they
never had to buy those oatmeal cookies
with the icing on them oh yeah right at
Dollar General and that was like the
only snack that you had yeah yeah they
never added to you they probably
wouldn't even know what we're talking
about but you guys know what we were
talking about you know they didn't grow
up in a trailer park and like [__]
like I did
so it's you know
I I don't know it's it'd be nice to have
like money enough money that I didn't
have to worry about anything
that's all I ever wanted yeah because I
hate having to worry all the time that's
the shitty thing yeah and I think that's
like something that people that have
never
struggled for money I think that's
something that they don't it's just a
constant yeah it just constantly sits on
your head you're always worrying all the
time about how am I going to pay this
I'm like kind of inescapable it is yeah
because and it's hard to crawl out of
there were times I was making a lot of
money
you know
well a lot of money from my point of
view I've been like 60 Grand probably
and uh I've built up a lot of [__]
that's when I was living up in Boston
so what ended up happens that all I did
was start worrying about losing the [__]
that I built up which I eventually did
lose it but the company went out of
business
but
it doesn't matter you kind of come back
but the thing is is that the people that
we're talking about and I mean like the
[__] top half a percentage of the
[__] worlds they never really can't
lose enough to ever be poor
that's what I'm saying it's not it's not
like they have to like oh my God I have
to go work at McDonald's and live in a
car I'm not a billionaire anymore I'm
now I'm only a multi-millionaire oh my
gosh
yeah like I said it's not like they had
to like move in with relatives because
they didn't have any [__] money like
I had to do yeah well no nothing like he
could lose everything but then they'd
still have a mansion or two somewhere
that was all paid for that they could
live in for the rest of their life I
just I have a couple million dollars
they could live on for the rest of their
life that's what I mean it's like I'm
sure they have stuff they can sell like
if they really needed some liquid assets
I just don't have any sympathy because
look
like I all I got is [__] my bank account
and my 20 year old [__] car that's it
that's all the assets I got
so something bad happens to me like I
have to I have a huge medical bill or
something like that I'm hosed yeah I'm
hosed yeah when I was uh living in
Brazil when I was as a kid
mom was in the state department I went
to a a school an International High
School called Escola di Sao Paulo that
had all the [__] Rich Kids the uh all
the Rich Kids of Brazil their ruling
class went to high school with me
uh the president of Brazil the king of
Brazil well they don't really have a
king anymore but the guy who would have
been king of Brazil name is Louise he
was a friend of mine it had been the
king of Brazil
um and uh the Santos family that owned
all of the [__] Television Studios
and all the [__] movie theaters
so I knew that people they were [__]
spoiled man they were our psycho
sociopaths and um how could they not
they're [__] sociopaths and they
[__] just treat people as pawns uh
regular people are just [__] like
tools uh and they're above everything
they're like little miniature gods they
could kill somebody literally and get
away with it they have enough [__]
money to get by lawyers and bribe people
and
yeah it's like Mafia dance well I was
thinking that only Brazil and South
America was like that but as I got older
and started to realize what the folks
going no America's like that too
our ruling class is exactly the same
they're Above the Law the law is only
for you
it's only for the poor people
well yeah I mean anybody with like a
huge amount of money is going to be able
to get away with whatever
yep it's always worked like that yep
rules are just for the little guy
yep just for a little guy
so you don't [__] trouble yeah they
got private detective agencies and
private security agencies made up of
Special Forces guys and ex-fbi guys and
ex-state police guys
and [__] ex-gangsters and they can
do hits on people and do it the right
way so no there's no forensic evidence
left behind and there'll never be any
indictment and if they ever come up as a
suspect they got some they can pull
strings inside the [__] courts to
make sure the indictments don't happen
and they can do anything
psych organized crime
yeah like I said you got money you can
pretty much deal with anything Matthew
Mac said when you asked if uh about
being gay before to answer Tom I am
straight slash bi tend to be 50 50. oh
these are into men or women okay
as long as you got good taste I'm all
right with it
thank you Tom I'm sure everyone wanted
your approval on that
oh [__]
is it time for another drink do you
think you want me to give you one sure
why not yeah I'll make you one we're not
going anyplace yeah it's Friday night
I'm so [__] happy this has been a
[__]
I don't know man this it seemed like a
week from hell you know what I mean it
wasn't a week from hell it was just
it was one of those weeks where you know
you know how it's one of those weeks and
you just like have work and you're just
like oh [__] okay there's a lot and then
it just keep piling on and piling and
you haven't even finished this [__] yet
and then it's just like how the [__] am
I gonna finish all this I still haven't
finished all of it but I finished enough
of it to not care anymore so there's
that but I get I
like I said I'm a very I'm an
overthinker kind of person
so when I have that happen
um I tend to get I get overwhelmed like
really easily so it's just kind of like
I like to just kind of like relax and do
one thing at a time it's like I have to
do this and then I have to do this and
then I have lists and everything I have
to because otherwise I'd lose track and
I'd freak out so because that's just how
I roll but this week it was just kind of
like not only did I have like my regular
job
where it was just like [__] kept coming
in and [__] kept going like dude I
haven't even finished this last thing
and now we're just kind of like hey can
you finish that by noon today and hey
can you do this and that and then it was
that and then like I had all this like
on the side I had all this freelance
stuff coming in like this and this and
this and I was just like holy [__] when
the and I was like when am I gonna have
time to do any of this stuff and I was
just like flipping out about it so you
know I tried to like [__] calm down I
try to remain Zen but I don't know it's
hard because it's like not in my nature
I'm not I'm not a Zen person I'm like a
I'm a really like [__] overthinking
anxiety written person and I'm trying
not to be like that but that's kind of
what I'm like so this whole week has
been like that so I'm just like so
[__] happy
that it's Friday night now and I got
pretty much most of the important [__]
done
um and then the other [__] I didn't get
done I don't really give a [__] about it
I'll push it off till Monday I'm not I
don't care
um so yeah I'm just gonna try and like
have a weekend which should be nice
because I don't usually but
I don't know it should be fine I might
I'm not gonna do a video this weekend
maybe like I might do like a movie
review I've already got some movie
reviews like
planned
um
but we'll see I don't I don't know which
one I'm gonna do though I have like four
of them
sort of written out like movies that I
watched before that I was gonna review
that I never got around to so I'm gonna
do that but I'm hoping to at least get
one of them if you haven't like
subscribed to my other channels by the
way you probably should I have one
called scare salon and one called crime
immemorial crime Memorial I just posted
one on the Santa Rosa hitchhiker murders
last week and
and it was like an hour long
it was like an hour long
so I worked really hard on that one so
yeah I should go watch it it's more ice
in this one uh Zach says I like your big
ring Jenny oh thank you which one
this one the black one or
yeah I buy these um like they have them
on Amazon and Shan and stuff like that
they just have like these big
sets of rings it's just like you know
like a dozen of them or 20 of them or
something like that for like [__]
three bucks they're cheap like they'll
break sometimes but
you just buy them in big in bulk you
know yeah the big black one yeah I
bought a um a set that was just like all
black rings they were all like black I
had this one and I have one that's like
barbed wire there's one that's like an
octopus one of his little tentacles
broke off though
John Gore said if you got money you have
to worry about others taking it or
stealing or scamming it yeah but they've
still got a bunch left
yeah if somebody's if somebody got into
my bank account took my money um I'd be
completely broke
so I would I would have zero money left
those guys there can lose [__] 90 of
their [__] and still have millions of
dollars left that's what I mean so it's
like I don't feel like they could they
could retire on that five million that
they had
and uh then they'd have a bunch of
assets that they owned some of they
could sell off
they could have one mansion and then
[__] take everything they sold off
and then the money they had just put it
in a [__] bag and just live off that
for the rest of their lives as long as
they didn't do anything crazy but they
do crazy [__] they want to be flying
around everywhere and on a [__] Fleet
of jets and
constantly vacationing and places and
hopping from one Mansion to the next so
they they eat up a lot of money that
they didn't okay
that way yeah
look I can't stay in this Mansion what
the [__] should I be in that Mansion
[__] on the internet having fun or
[__] the rest that's what I mean it's
like [__] man I'll just live in here
I'll die in here yeah all right
have a [__] party have a whole ghetto
party have all the goth kids over
looking all the strippers up on the
poles and [__] [__] it'd be great
we'd have the best parties
man people still talk about the party
that we had a couple years I know they
still talk about that
and that was like four or five years ago
we had that party that wasn't that
didn't even have sex in it that wasn't
even that crazy yeah people were still
talking about that yeah that people are
still talking about I had a [__] DJ
here from we had the DJ from [__]
momentum already [__] our buddy we
had the smoke machine going the cats
were [__] tripping out yeah he
brought all the lights and everybody the
lights it was awesome it was barbecuing
I had Indian food had the vegan black
metal Chef was over yeah we had we had a
whole Buffet of like Indian food and uh
we had that was a fun party I like well
it was an awesome party and I liked that
the house wasn't trash not in trash
because see goth people are very they're
they're crazy but they're also like very
respectful well I'm not gonna mess up
the house did nobody broke anything
nobody
[__] anything up
nobody the cops were not called no I
don't think were they no they're laser
beams and [__] [__] coming out of the
[__] windows and hitting all the
houses it was [__] funny yeah that's
right
all the names they didn't [__] though
smoke machine set off the [__] fire
alarm
[Music]
that was a good party it was a good time
man I got head I got super hammered but
I I was hammered like in a good way
because I said okay look I'm in my own
house I don't got to go nowhere like
everybody was over it was everybody it
was a good vibe it was like sitting out
on the patio like smoking pot it was
like it was a good it was a good vibe uh
Jenna Shea and Brie and her boyfriend
the whole threesome was over no that's
right remember that or was Jenna said no
Bree was gone by that time it was just
wait was that when they were still
trying to be a trio yeah that was even
though Brie was like I don't know yeah
yeah I knew she was I knew she wasn't
you're talking about this guy the couple
I knew she wasn't into that I told you
dude's name is Damien
and he was in a band and he was also an
artist
he's cool yeah damn is real cool he's
tall thin
kind of mixed guy you know kind of
light-skinned black guy goth [__]
real good looking and he had this real
[__] hot girlfriend Bree there's
another God check and then he had
another girlfriend who's a high God
stripper
named [__] Jetta Shay yeah all three
of them were a [__] thing for a while
that was that was a trip yeah they used
to come out all three
but I knew that Brie was not happy about
well they were fighting well because
well the thing about it was that Damien
and Brie had been just the two of them
for a long time yeah and then a third
person came into the situation and I was
like and I always kind of got the sense
when they came out debris was like yeah
into it she was just kind of like I'm
just going along with this because
that's what he wants but I just kind of
always got that I don't know but I'm
just because she never told me that but
that was just the impression I got from
the body language I didn't quite get
that that impression I did I got the
impression that they were
that she was fighting over him yeah but
I don't know
but Damien and Jenna Shay are still
together yeah they actually sell art at
mannequins yeah on Friday nights most of
most Friday nights because they put
they're out on the patio now right yeah
because I thought that they I was like
what did they kick them out because last
time we were there I was like they used
to have a booth in the club
like by the back bar but then last time
I was there was like oh it's not there
anymore and but then we'll be out on the
patio and they were there that's Damian
yeah yeah there's Dave yeah yeah he's
super cool yeah
oh you [__] the [__] there's
another cool picture damn it
very popular guy
there's Damian and Jenna Shea
yeah they've been together a long time
now yeah
yeah they're they're solid now
they've been together yeah a long time
long time
we hadn't seen Brie for a while because
she kind of disappeared yeah we saw her
at the but we just saw her at Memento
not this past one but the one before
that that's a good picture of them
they're a cute couple they're real nice
oh yeah that's good yeah yeah you can
see them
yeah I like them yeah I like breiti
though
see if I can find a picture of Bree
but yeah I was surprised he's smoking
too I was surprised to see her because
we hadn't seen her in such a long time
and she was at Memento yeah like I said
not the one we went to not last Friday
but the couple weeks ago
because I was like holy [__] where have
you been there's Bree
man that's a good picture of her yeah
I didn't see that picture but that's a
really good picture of her
foreign
she's got a lot of good ones here I want
to show one to capture it trying to
capture the [__] trying to capture her
yeah
I wonder if there's one picture that
captures my Essence yeah there's several
there's several there's several of them
yeah is it the one that you have on your
tablet yeah it's one of them there's a
lot of them
yes on his tablet his um his background
photo
that pretty much counts yeah yeah yeah
that's a good one that's pretty much
cash yeah that's her yeah that's her all
right
ha
but yeah on his tablet like on the
background photo
he has one of the ones that I took in
one of the
shoots
and what hair did I have
for what the black hair the braids black
hair with braids yeah I'll show it and
the big round glasses don't share the
don't show the titties though yes
because it's just covered up I mean
we'll probably get demonetized I don't
know but it's okay we've already been
demonetize at this point
I think I have pictures of that without
okay Zach says you guys are always
talking about but I guess he means
Memento what is that exactly oh that is
our
um monthly or twice monthly goth night
that's from that same photo shoot I
can't show it all yeah because there's
boobs oh yeah I zoomed in oh you [__]
assumed into a boob
s
your tablet knows what you want yeah
it's like yeah I basically just want to
say okay that's I just want to see
that's the exact photo right there which
one is that
okay yeah yeah that's right
what the [__] people
quit touching it you're touching it I'm
touching this [__] too much yeah it's
called memente Mori and it's been going
for nine years ten years yeah yeah I
send Dimitri like we started it at the
old independent bar downtown
and it was once a month
and um it was on Monday actually I think
it started on Sundays and then they
moved it to Monday and then when
Barbarella moved to the other club like
in the warehouse District they started
doing it on Friday night so they do it
every usually like once a month on
Fridays unless there's like a holiday
and then they'll do it sometimes twice a
month but that's that's like the goth
Knight that photo disappeared did it
really yeah it's gone
did you you throw it in the garbage oh I
wanted to [__] uh here's something
else oh
what else did you think of oh
we were talking a couple shows back
about the girl I was trying trying to
[__] get for Jen
oh are we allowed to show or don't do
that okay I'm not sure
you're bad
I mean I don't know that was her yeah
that was her that's her
laughs
she was at Memento yeah that's her last
Friday yeah with her boyfriend yeah
she got a good boyfriend
yeah he's cool I like yeah he's Irish
Irish yeah
Snappy good dresser
good outfit
who
her boyfriend oh okay he had to get out
yeah yeah
I like a dude that knows how to dress
is what I'm saying he had a good outfit
too young for me but
you know I don't know what happened to
that
did you [__] it up I was showing it I
had it and now it's gone
I didn't delete it again
you'll find it
it's almost kind of like maybe it took
it out of order I don't know Zach says
the gay bar I go to has like a twice
monthly leather night and it's annoying
as [__] because I want to try Kink and
there's dudes in gear everywhere and
they might be the lightning might be the
lighting might be the lighting all red
what does that mean
I don't know he's crazy
You misspelled it dude
what's up well people are doing the the
yeah you know
the thing where you type and it's what's
what's that called where you type in it
helps you oh uh speed type I hate that
[__] I was like don't help me I know
what I'm saying
you're just giving me the wrong words I
think I might have actually thrown that
into the garbage
did you throw me in the garbage Tom I
don't know how I'm gonna [__] get
where would that [__] be in your garbage
can yeah how do I find that it's in
control how would I know I don't have
that I don't know how your tablet works
it'll be storage Maybe
yeah normally
um I'm not sure how many nights a week
Barbarella is open now now that it's in
the different building
um
it's normal they're big night is
Saturday night and that's 80s that's
like 80s New Wave which is also super
fun that's actually like my favorite
club night
and it was when they were downtown as
well
um because it's just it's fun the the um
all the regulars are we know all of them
and it's like it's super fun and it's
like the music is fun
Friday nights
um I don't know if they do a regular
Friday night but every
once a month or sometimes twice a month
they do Memento Mori and that's like
goth Industrial
so that's kind of when and like I said I
kind of like
I missed the old place because
um the place that they used to have the
bar used to be like which was right on
the corner of um orange and Washington
in downtown Orlando which you can look
up on Google Earth obviously
um is [__] iconic I mean that's an
iconic building it had been there for 30
[__] years more than 30 years
actually
and when they moved it was kind of a big
bummer the building's still there
obviously I think it's been another club
but
that's another one that captures Jen
that's in my white wig yeah
I think my big ass nose it's time big
that's okay I don't I'm Zen with it now
I don't I'm very ambivalent about that
white wig like I bought it
and I'm kind of like sometimes I like it
and sometimes I don't
Jen looks really good in white
I think I also had the green contacts in
in that shot
I have green contacts and I have blue
ones also I have red ones but I don't
know what happened to
and I also have snake eye ones because I
use this for my Medusa costume but I
don't know what happened to those either
they're in my bathroom someplace
Zach says they also do a drag show at
the bar on Wednesdays and Jesus Christ
I've been in IMAX theaters where the
speakers weren't that bass heavy liquify
your organs type [__]
Zach says did you at least put Jenny in
a nice dumpster somewhere right at least
I mean there could be a mattress in the
bottom at least
James says should be a trash bin in your
photo gallery Tom photo gallery yeah I'm
looking Gallery oh man don't know how
[__] Works looking for the trash
although to be honest if I if I had to
find trouble yeah it went right to the
trash yeah it's where it was if you had
if I had to find trash on my phone I
probably would be able to find it either
I know where the trash is on my computer
but I don't know restore it right yeah
yeah okay
okay there you go that's it you figured
it out thank you James thanks man
I'll show you
thanks for helping out the old people
yeah my hand somehow hit a control
somewhere and [__] do this dude I
feel you my phone I don't know if it's
because like my phone has been dropped
okay like several times
and it has like cracks in the in the
[__] I probably need a new one but
you can just like if you want it to do
something it won't do it like you push
push push and like nothing happens but
seriously if you don't wanted to do
something you just like [__] breathe
on it wrong it'll do all kind of crazy
[__] like it'll send messages to people
It'll like yeah
what the [__] man
do it again did it again
I don't know why it's zooming it's
[__] hilarious that's it because
you're touching it yeah I do like that
that's one of the best pictures of Jack
I like my pout yeah I'm just like yeah
she's got her braids in overhead
to pout but that's just like my natural
expression and we got those glasses now
in [__] they're coming finally had to
order them from [__] China AliExpress
yeah
they shift
because we have a [__] of a time
because he loves those glasses I like
those glasses but those are costume
glass I can't [__] see [__] in those
it's just glass it's not yeah they were
only like five bucks right so it does
it's not like just for photos yeah it
doesn't like blow anything up yeah so we
finally found on AliExpress they finally
we finally found a pair of glasses that
looked almost like that that were
actually
that I would actually see in you could
order them yeah to uh magnification
right
hopefully they'll be here in a couple of
days yeah thanks James yeah it was
there's a trash bin right there in the
photo gallery I was looking for the main
trash
says I like the anime school teacher
glasses I hate mine because my lenses
are like a half inch to an inch thick
because my eyes are awful always
cleaning them
yeah that's kind of the shitty thing is
that
I could see I had badass Vision until
when fairly recently yeah because you
used to ask me to like read stuff man we
got 19 likes our [__] um viewers are
going up actually okay people in the
longer the longer we stay on the more
people and the drunker we get we're not
going anywhere this is this is Friday
let me go ahead and pass the collection
plate around again we haven't played any
commercials or anything like that if you
guys want to give us a Super Chat we
would [__] love it it all goes to pay
these bam bills around this house
next thing you know I have to pimp this
woman out man [__] you're going to
have to help me prevent pimping the
pimpage
you better not pit me yeah but what
we're talking about we're talking about
uh
he uh
you're weird about that time why do you
want to pimp me out no I don't know
[Laughter]
tipping myself out
that's okay we're all pimping ourselves
out in one way or another there's
something I was going to talk about
what's that I forgot what it was
um alcohol's getting to me
can you get in the ballpark it was what
we were talking about you were talking
about it there was something I was gonna
say the glasses glasses exactly okay
she knows I know she knows I can read
your mind
it's easier now that you're bald I don't
have all that hair glasses
I don't know what it is
I guess it's because I'm a guy
I got real good taste in women's clothes
I almost should have been a drag queen
or something [__] I could probably
you still could I probably could always
could go a drag sure but [__] um I
see [__] I've got my head look that
might be a great Niche for you that'd
look real good on Jen and um he says
that all the time like literally what's
that every time like we're out somewhere
and he'll see some chick let's like we
gave some pants like that yeah those
pants look good on you that's good they
look better on you than they look on her
and he says I don't know yeah same thing
with the glasses she wears glasses
when she's working just the readers just
readers I sound the same way when I have
to read something about reading glasses
on
and they got so many cool glasses out
there now
so I'm like man we gotta get her some
[__] fashion readers
that she could wear on the show
and those brown ones were the [__]
first thing that came to my mind a big
oversized round retro it's like some
sexy [__] yeah like 70s Rocky Mountain
High Colorado sure there's like some
[__] [__] oh what's his name John
Denver John Denver will wear those
[__] but there's just something
cute everybody wore those in the 70s
yeah there's something real cute about
big round glasses makes your face look
smaller yeah it probably makes all your
features look smaller too yeah but you
put them on and it fits it's like some
neotony [__] yeah
but there's got to be some other ones
over there uh there's got to be other
ones out there too that would work I'm
like I'm gonna keep my eye out for them
I do like the big round ones I didn't
think that I would because I thought I
was like oh my God I'll look like the
[__] 70s and it's like but I was like
oh you know what
that looks pretty good and every time
I'm seeing them now they're on a goth
girl
yeah weirdly yeah even like the ones
when we finally found the big round ones
because these are kind of these are more
cat eye and I like these too but um the
big round ones
um that I have this is what she's
talking about yeah these that like I
said I'll take them off but I can't she
can't see I can't see like I can't see
in these but they look cool so I wear
them for photos and stuff but it's like
yeah everything's just a blur so we were
looking for a pair like these but that
had magnification because these don't
have any
and it was surprisingly difficult
yeah we finally did find a pair on like
I said AliExpress and interestingly the
model photo was a goth chick yeah with
the glasses on and they're almost
exactly the same as these I think they
are the same but readers I think I think
they're the same frame and everything
okay
can't see
I mean I can see but they're just
flattering super blurry they're just a
flattering
glass like I said it's like because I
have a giant face so it like makes my
face look smaller which is always good I
think you don't have a Giant's face
Zach says Tom is a drag queen is an
upsetting combination
I know I don't know how it might work no
Well it Well if you had your own kind of
no you could do it nah I feel like I
have a hyper masculine build that would
never work
but see but if you leaned into that in
some way that would work oh come on
we're gonna have fun
no
Zach says I love the look of giant 70s
glasses but I don't think I could pull
them off who said that Zack Zack said
that yeah
I didn't think I could either because
when because normally like the the
reading glasses that I usually use she
was skeptical when I gave them to her
yeah the reading glasses that I usually
use just for regular work around they're
just kind of like small
like sort of rectangular
um and I was just like used to those so
he's like I think he should get these
big round ones and I was like I don't
think that's gonna look good
took a picture and after a few after she
said I was like um
like I said it does make my face look
smaller yeah which is always a good
thing it just no it's just cute like you
said it's like niagne
giving up an adult kind of childlike
appearances or childlike
like anime
anime is very the very neatness
that's what that's what it talks about
yeah like an adult person with like with
child juvenile features
um James says that rockabilly aesthetic
is sexy not gonna lie yeah I love the I
hope I love the whole rockabilly thing
says can you imagine Tom in a sexy maid
outfit I think so come on Tom you got
that you got this I don't have to ask
for it are you [__] you gotta if
you're gonna be in the sexy maid outfit
you gotta have a big meaty [__] ass I
got a little ass it's [__] a little
Tom has a little cute purse no it would
never work
[Laughter]
I don't know I think it might never work
I think it could
have no fun Thomas
he's no fun now she's trying to get more
out of me than than is there I don't
know about maid outfit I'm trying to
think of like some other kind of like
drag outfit he could do
I don't know I'd have to think about it
more
like I said I think like the whole day
we had this whole running joke about
um
how my big fantasy was like seeing him
and David Bowie
like having sex and then it's like one
of the things and I think this is [__]
up but like when David Bowie died I was
like and that's like not funny because I
was like super upset about it like
seriously we went to ibar when it was
still downtown and like a day or two
after David Bowie died
and they did a big like tribute and they
played like not all David Bowie but like
a lot of David Bowie songs and man
everybody was crying it was awful and
it's like it was awesome but it was like
awful at the same time so it's like we
were there doing that and then I was
like and then one thing that I thought
and I said to him later I was like so my
fantasy is Never Gonna Come True not
like it would anyway because it's like
we're never gonna meet David Bowie come
on but um but yeah so I told Tom that
it's like it's never gonna come true now
because he's dead hahaha
I don't know we're [__] weird like
that Tom and of course it yeah see I
keep telling I kind of wish like even if
nobody saw it I was just kind of like I
would like him to like have to wear a
corset like super high heels and all
that kind of stuff just for a while just
to like go out in and just to see like
how
difficult it is and like I said I don't
mind it because I like the way it looks
but it is a pain in the ass it is a pain
in the ass
um and you can't
uh wearing a corset especially
is
you don't really have a lot of Mobility
you know what I mean like you can't
really bend over
um you know so if you are like sitting
down it's kind of hard to stand up it's
like I don't like if I'm going out I
don't really like to sit so I have to
kind of stand all night so there's that
kind of stuff too but it's like like I
said I wouldn't wear it if I if it
annoyed me that much but it is kind of a
pain in the ass so I kind of wish that
he could do that just so he could
experience it you know what are you
talking about wearing a corset I ain't
worried about it of course you're not
worried about don't worry about that too
and it's like an own corset and I always
kind of internal corset no I'm just
saying that like wearing one would be
um nice if you wore one like one night
like we were going out just so you could
see what it was wearing wearing it on
one night where'd this [__] come from no
because somebody said I believe the
exact same time in a corset yeah and
that just reminded me of that
we were like laughing about the maid
outfit though I was like I don't really
know I don't really like not really into
the maid outfit thing
if it's latex Maybe
I guess
I do like the latex outfits yeah I like
the latex like nurses we can kind of get
you some latex probably late thanks for
the show for the [__] stream probably
yeah I should probably get them because
I don't really have to oil yourself
though to keep so just [__] pull on
you yeah because they'd be like yeah
yeah
get like a latex nurse or the latex
maybe that too
yeah we're just regular just latex
yeah I feel like maybe I don't know
do we really want like the nerd because
so many people have that like so stop it
I'd go for something that's just like
black and red yeah I feel like it's
probably better to just get more General
basically the same kind of mini dress
like this yeah latex because I mean
we've been having like decent success on
streammate just with wearing
just the regular like the short dresses
yeah because it's easy to like pop your
titties out of it it's easy access right
it's like they're short so you can kind
of like you know show legs and I have
tights with like the um
like the the garters on them yeah so
it's like so you can kind of see that so
it's just kind of like
and they're comfortable because we're
basically the way around down floor yeah
the way we have it set up now it's
basically we're just like on the floor
so we've got a nice [__] little rug
yeah we got a rug and pillows and stuff
yeah so we have to have some so I don't
like wear shoes or anything like that
because we have to just like crawl
around on the floor
well one dude request issues though yeah
if we do have shoes there like if
somebody wants but I don't like wear
them for the show because like I said I
have to crawl around and they're just I
totally understand though I have I have
a shoe finish I [__] love shoes on
women
and the more evil those shoes look the
more I like them
yeah
did you show that did you show that pair
of shoes like last time that is your
favorite oh my show they're right here
these are pretty basic though which ones
he's right here oh yeah this is a basic
thing yeah that's pretty basic that guy
requested those yeah
[Laughter]
I think I've worn those out one time
very painful they are very painful yeah
they look cool though we got these
now those I've just worn regular yeah
because those are they don't look like
it but those are fairly comfortable
now if you stand and dance in them too
long then yeah they do kind of like [__]
up your toes but they're very cute but I
like those
they're not as uncomfortable as those
other ones
because at least there's like some
support in there she's got big old
[__] long boots to go up to the knees
Spikes all over them
yeah I got lots of shoes like that and
those like I said I've danced in those
like for hours and hours and it's fine
but sometimes like my feet will hurt the
next day but
but those high-heeled ones I can't I can
barely even walk at those
they're just two
precarious
it's 10 30. you know that super curious
yeah I know I can see okay I can see
like I said it's Friday night we're not
going anywhere so okay Pookie let go of
it Pookie with it what do you know she's
got a claws cutting it oh
you all right did you get it
we were talking about
maybe getting her a friend
get her a friend to put the keeper
occupy Zach's now thinking about getting
a big old frame big old pair of [__]
round frame glasses
I mean like I said it depends on the
face depends on your face I round
glasses look really good on me but small
ones
I haven't worn them in a long time but I
used to have some
yeah you're glad the glasses you have
are pretty like standard yeah
regularized glasses
but see I didn't think like big huge
round retro glasses would look good on
my face either but then I was just like
ow all right
because I don't know I just never really
liked them personally they gotta have a
thin wire frame around them too can't be
real thick
like those little Harry Potter ones
there's a lot smaller but it's thick it
looks pretty good
as long as you got the eyebrow right
over it looks good yeah because I have
some of those too yeah those only look
good with certain wigs though yeah I've
noticed
yeah like I got these ones Victor asked
where's Beijing she's down she's
downstairs she's sitting on a couch yeah
she looks out the back she sleeps on the
back of the couch and like looks out the
back sliding glass door like pretty much
all the time yeah and she rarely rarely
comes upstairs
see I like these two but I don't I think
they look better with the black wig yeah
because they're very
heavy you know what I mean yeah I don't
really think those work with it around
the kind of
eyebrow that you have on right now
because she doesn't really have eyebrows
those are painted on that this has to be
kind of a higher arching eyebrow I think
to go over that yeah maybe
yeah I just had the same eyebrows that I
had for work today yeah because I have
to draw them on well see that's the
thing it's I had this whole
deal with the eyebrows where for
10 11 12 years I just shaved the [__]
off so I just like drew it on and then
for some reason like last year I was
like you know what I'm gonna grow my
eyebrows back so I grew them back and
then I was like oh wow I forgot what a
pain is Jack says that those that those
glasses are missing the nose and the men
[Laughter]
sort of looks like I need some Harpo
Mark's action because maybe that's what
I he said that because your eyebrows are
not quite right for that
for that [__] size frame if you're
gonna wear that your eyebrows have to be
up a little bit higher and they have to
be kind of [__] straight arched I'm
not rounded but
like a [__] a big a big traditional
[__] 80s goth [__]
eyebrow would work for that it goes like
this you know big ass big ass [__]
shh like that
foreign
it can't be round because then you have
two circles one above the other
yeah I get it yeah
I get it all right you talk I'm gonna go
pee this is good she's gonna go to the
rest well this is the first time I've
actually been joking you've been several
times
yeah
look at that ass
go ahead and take the Cam's captain's
chair taking the Cabbage chair on us
yeah
she's like
all right let's see what y'all up too I
can barely read
okay and Zach's talking about the
Instagram eyebrow Trend I'm not really
quite sure what you're talking about
Zach what is the Instagram what is the
Instagram eyebrow trend
see she just leaves she just wants me to
[__] talk
like I can just talk out of my head like
this I'm not really like that though
[Laughter]
foreign
thick and boxy eyebrows
I wouldn't really know anything about
that I never seen the Kardashians that's
that's too uh that's too Normie for me I
don't even know what that is I mean I
could have seen them but I don't
remember yeah
yeah I don't really remember what they
look like
okay
oh there we go that's much better
yeah that's the thing it's like I can't
even keep track of all this like eyebrow
Trends you know what I mean I'm just
like whatever I'm just gonna like
[__] like I said I thought that I'd
grow them back and I'm just like oh I'll
kind of keep them plucked and everything
like that and then I'm like oh yeah this
is a pain in the ass this is why I
shaved them off in the first place
because I can just draw them on however
you want it's a pain in the ass either
way I wish I looked good without
eyebrows nobody looks good with that
eyebrow except Gia Gia yeah we have a
friend named Gia who doesn't have any
eyebrows and she doesn't bother putting
and she looks [__] yeah without
eyebrows and it's like every time I say
see that's the thing that I have you
heard the most about I'm like God damn
it I wish I looked that good with that
eyebrows so I didn't really draw them
off is that [__] up
because she's so [__] kid she looks
so [__] good with that eyebrows
but I mean I guess I could go around
without eyebrows but
people look at me like [__] G it was
with Jay
j i a right no it's g i g i
I can't remember her screen name was
though yeah I don't think that's her
screen name because she's not coming up
yeah she had she had a different screen
name yeah yeah so I don't know what her
screen name is
but she's like yeah she's one of the
only people that I knew personally that
likes looks really good without eyebrows
cute lesbian Shake
she moved to New Orleans but she moved
back here though didn't she yeah she's
back and then I think she went back no
she was here only for a little while she
went so she went back somewhere else
all right hey here here's a here's a
good one there's me with a bunch of
[__] warlocks and stuff
I can't see anything Tom
what was that bike night oh okay that
must have been a while back yeah yeah
hold on like I said you should go back
you haven't been in a long time they're
all missing you
it's all that glare yeah you can see
it's the ring light yeah
where's that at
that was at that um bike night I knew
that but I mean where exactly was that
downtown was that in front of mannequins
or no that was that um
throwbacks
where's that at across the street from
mannequins and up oh oh yeah yeah the
Retro I know the retro 80s arcade oh
yeah yeah yeah that's right I've never
been in there but I've passed it that's
out front of it
it's little Smalls
hahaha
yeah they have a thing every Tuesday
night in downtown Sanford and everybody
all the bikers go down there and hang
out like for most of the day
most of the evening I guess
kind of go around to the different bars
and kind of hang up
because like sometimes we get a
mannequins on Friday night and it's like
some of the bike night people are there
and then it's like hey it's Tom
sport bikes and Harleys
yeah it's a nice crowd it seems yeah
then it gets dark
downtown Sanford is actually
um it's small but it's actually like a
pretty nice that's my friends Harley
Quinn little area Hayabusa
it was this Harley Quinn themed Hayabusa
he's got three Hayabusas
a little shorty
that's what it's like at night
you have about [__] 60 bikes out
there's some Harleys
cops come
the Stanford cops are there's my buddy's
Chopper
chops Forester
he's got 70 Style
that is pretty cool yeah
that's my bike next to it
you can't really see much of it though
this is my bike one of them
my bill
yeah
yeah you got a good shot of it there
yeah my bike's famous around here
if you can't buy that bike you got to
build it like I said not nobody has that
nobody has that bike
to build a fireball with a lightning
tail on it and a bunch of bunch of Uh
custom modifications
okay Zach says I guess 70s natural
makeup and clothes are kind of making a
comeback which I like because that stuff
looks so easy and comfortable I mean I
like that stuff too but I don't know
well and the thing about it is that
coming from kind of the Gotham Punk
scene almost always I'm always kind of
like
if I'm gonna wear makeup I want it to
look like makeup I don't want it to look
like oh I have makeup on but I want it
to look like I don't have any makeup on
you know what I'm saying
like I want it to look deliberate
I know there's a whole like no makeup
makeup look
you know and I kind of feel like some
people is like oh look I have no makeup
on except they do
but they're just trying to make it look
like they don't have any makeup on
I'm not into that
if you're gonna have makeup on I want it
to look like you have makeup on you know
what I mean like I want it to look like
[__] crazy so I'm kind of more into
that but I get it you know I get the
whole
70s were very
uh
you know they they wanted to be kind of
overall natural we've all got Bush and
honestly which like I said that's cool
but you know
I'm not into that myself
but certain aspects of that look worked
it depends on the person it will just
kind of like everything else like so on
some people it works and some people not
so much I thought certain elements
worked and other elements didn't it you
know what I mean it was a mixture of
stuff like
some of the 70s hair was good some of it
was bad yeah
the female the female Styles in general
looked better than the male styles
I've seen some 70s looks that were kind
of like goth and biker that they had
back then it looked really good but
there were certain elements in it that
didn't didn't look good like they were
wearing Fringe and [__] I didn't really
like that yeah it was just not really
about The Fringe it was the mixtures
that were there but then every now and
then you'd see one
where the the the the
outfit looked tight you're like yeah
that does look good
they had the same problems that we had
in the 80s and the 90s sourcing you
couldn't go to a store to buy that [__]
right you couldn't find it
and what they were selling off the rack
was just like corporate almost communist
[__] Mass [__]
mass production clothes they look like
everything else people wore they were
generic
um the people with the best clothes were
people that could afford designer Custom
Clothes Like David Bowie David Bowie by
Japanese stuff he was buying boots that
inspired all the goth boots
from Japanese designers like the big
platforms and stuff
God boots came from David Bowie and he
got that from Japan a lot of goth came
from David Bowie yeah and Velvet
Underground yeah
um
yeah Bowie would wear [__] like [__]
jumpers but then they were like
knee-high like a jumpsuit but it only
went up to your knee
and long sleeved and he'd wear those
[__] boots with it looked really good
it's like he's wearing like a turquoise
jumpsuit look like something from space
and then he'd have a mullet which he
thought was high-tech as [__] but it was
all [__] a bullet it'd be [__]
bright red with an eye patch on you know
it's just crazy [__]
I didn't really understand
I was a big Bowie fan coming up as a
teenager I didn't understand what I was
seeing a lot of times but I just enjoyed
it just I liked his style loved his
music
now I know he's LARPing
and then and then he was doing he was
LARPing in every [__] like decades
before long before there was a thing
called Barbara
come out with an album and he's another
he's a new character right on that album
it's LARPing you know LARPing as a dude
who thinks he's an alien rock star well
he was applying he's applying to an
album what writers would apply to a
novel there you go it was multimedia it
was right it was all kinds he was kind
of one of the first people to do that
yeah and it was ahead of his time and we
didn't really know what was going on
well who's him he's a character in every
one of those albums none of that's him
right yeah
[__] genius um
way ahead of his time and this is
and you know what's funny is that I
remember in the uh
like around 94 or 95 I saw an interview
with Bowie Bowie is predicting how the
internet would change everything
he says we're he said we're in an era
now where reality is dictated to you
through these television channels and he
says soon
every person will have their own
television channel there won't be a
center to it they'll just be a bunch of
different clicks each with their own
thing they're called it there won't be a
mainstream culture he [__] called it
called it
he foresaw you he was foreseeing the
effects of what YouTube would do and
social media
boy was the [__] man
he was the [__]
yeah he was like a Visionary yeah
and well I like that though I kind of
like like I said I do kind of miss some
things about the 80s but
I don't think that I would want to go
back because I do kind of I do like the
way that everything is a lot more
democratized nowadays like everyone can
just kind of do their own thing
they don't have Gatekeepers like they
used to well there's not there's only
four [__] networks in the United
States I mean in the 80s dictated
reality to you I mean in the 80s there
was a very distinct mainstream culture
yeah and that was something that if you
were into like an alternative subculture
like we were then you know that was
something I don't know if you were
necessarily rebelling against it but you
were just like yeah you're rejecting it
yeah
you're like lame I don't want to do that
but it's like nowadays I don't even know
if there's such a thing anymore no is
there no I wouldn't no but I'm just
saying it's almost tribal no now
everyone's just kind of got now it's
just like a whole bunch of subcultures
and like they each have their own thing
going on
yeah which Bowie foresaw that
and I remember when he was saying that
in the 90s I could only kind of Envision
what he was talking about but he was
right
I mean to be honest I don't other
outside of like
horror movies and like goth [__] and
like True Crime I have no [__] idea
what's going on otherwise yeah you know
what I mean like I read the news and
[__] like that but
I don't
focus on it that's kind of my whole main
thing well and nobody could because
there's just so much stuff happening so
it's just kind of like no one person can
keep track of all of it so you just kind
of have to focus on sex sandwiches like
70s he thinks of [__] Spacek [__]
Spacek had a 70s look that was kinda
she had an alternative sexy look I
remember her as a kid and I remember
like my babysitters and stuff talking
about her yeah when I was a little kid
[__] Spacek was almost kind of like a
goth girl for her time because she was
little and she was skinny and she was
cute and she was very vulnerable looking
and kind of dingy not real smart I would
say but in an endure endearing way she
would look very vulnerable
um but there's something about her look
is that she was um attractive
and there was something that you're
right there was a big 70s quality to her
um
it's like some chick you would meet at
the [__] Led Zeppelin concert or
something yeah
he's cute her being in Carrie was like
perfect casting perfect yeah
because she's like exactly the right
combination of
nerdy yeah Oddball and awkward yeah but
also like super cute so you could buy
that she got horribly bullied yeah and
you could also buy that you know if
somebody kind of like took the time to
like dress her up and [__] like that
that she would actually be quite
beautiful you could buy the top you
bought it you could buy the Tommy Ross
the character Tommy Ross not me
Tommy Ross would go for her yeah that's
what I mean that's why that's why I like
that adaptation because it's like
everything seems believable they did a
remake
um which was okay but Corey uh Chloe
Grace Moretz was in it and it's like no
one is gonna believe that Chloe Grace
[__] Moritz was bullied because she's
gorgeous so it's just kind of like and
Sissy's basic is gorgeous too but
gorgeous in a way right she's gorgeous
like in an oddball kind of way so you
could still kind of buy that she would
have been picked on she was very pretty
and very feminine but she had a Ghostly
quality to her when you looked at her
she had a very ghostly quality kind of
pale and very white and kind of sickly
looking
sad to say kind of sickly looking
[__] long blonde hair but still
pretty like it's like a ghost
yeah which I'm into that I like that
look yeah
so I was I always thought she was I
always thought she was beautiful she's
cute yeah Zach says she's like really
pretty but still looks like a normal
person and I love casting like that yeah
I think that was one of the things that
made that adaptation of Carrie so
enduring
um is that they really captured the
essence of that character because like I
said you could totally buy that she had
been picked on her whole entire life
like she was a little bit awkward and
stuff like that but then you could still
buy that she was like when she was
dressed up she was like really pretty
Elin like he still bought it it wasn't
like because you know how they made
those movies and it's they made a lot of
these in like the 90s and like the early
2000s
like movies like um what was that movie
called like she's all that and stuff
like that where it was just kind of like
oh here's this awkward nerdy girl and
it's basically like obviously like a
super hot girl that just has her hair
pulled back and glasses on and then it's
like oh later we'll take the glasses off
and put her hair down oh my God she's
gorgeous you know what I mean I'm just
like come on how dumb do you think we
are but it's you know what I mean so I
kind of feel like [__] Spacek had a
good like she's obviously beautiful but
you could still buy that she was like
bullied and awkward and stuff like that
time she had the genetics
she looked like something from Oklahoma
or [__] Appalachia or something you
know something from out in the country
yeah like like I said she looked like a
normal person she didn't look like a
Hollywood yeah like it like what you
would normally think of as like a
Hollywood Starlet type of person she had
like her own which I always kind of
found
a lot more attractive because like I
said they're more distinctive yeah the
hot you know hot actresses or whoever
are a dime a dozen and they all kind of
look alike after a while
so I kind of like ones that are that
have a distinctive look to them having
grown up all over the whole world born
in California but it was actually kind
of had roots in Mississippi and then
[__] growing up as a teenager in Sao
Paulo Brazil and then going to Korea and
all over the world Florida [__]
Louisiana I've been [__] Boston in
the New England area
people outside people in California New
York [__] don't have a good grasp on
what the rest of the country is like
they don't realize how pretty
people can really be in places like
Oklahoma or Mississippi or just out in
the middle of nowhere you can just run
into a person who's just
yeah they don't they might not look like
a California Superstar model
you know it's not that look it's a
different kind of look
um
and you know you might get if you're a
[__]
you know real sophisticated or something
it might be kind of turned off by you
know the the fact that they're not
wearing designer clothes or something
you know and they don't look like they
stepped out of a club now they had real
pretty women in the South especially in
the 70s and the 80s well there's pretty
people everywhere you know yeah and uh
cute
oh you were done
yeah all right yeah Victor said uh just
take off her glasses of ponytail yeah
it's like and I always kind of hated
that about
like I said a lot of those kind of and I
feel like this was maybe a 90s thing
but there was a lot of movies that came
out where it's just like oh ugly
duckling gets turned into like a hot
girl and it's like but that's very
obviously like a hot girl to start with
she just oh we're trying to make her
look nerdy we'll put some glasses on her
and pull her hair back and that's it
like oh maybe we'll put a dumpy sweater
on her yeah but it's like you could
still tell that that was like super hot
like she was a super hot yeah well
that's a that's a Spacey cat going
forward because she wasn't one of those
yeah she obviously she was just a
genuinely like naturally pretty
and she looked like a normal person but
like a beautiful normal person yeah but
she could be kind of like I said spooky
looking too I mean uh yeah you could put
her in the haunted house in [__]
Disneyland's haunted house and she'd fit
right in
hahaha
[Laughter]
that's like super funny but like I said
that's why that was like really good
casting and that's why I think like like
I said I love um
Chloe Grace Moritz but I think that them
casting her is Carrie in the remake
was probably
not the right decision because like
obviously everybody knows what she looks
like she's super cute to start with and
I just found it hard to believe that she
would be like picked on like looking the
way she looks
yeah they try to like nerd her up or
ugly her up or whatever but it's like it
didn't work she's still her you know
what I mean she still looks like that so
it's better to get somebody that's like
more regular looking but like I said and
I think that [__] Spacek like had that
and she's great in other [__] too like I
know she's probably the best name for
that but
Zach says or like an indie movie about
the
dull life of like a McDonald's cashier
but it's Angelina Jolie
I mean I'm not gonna lie I have seen
some just regular ass people just like
walking around that were just working in
a store or whatever that were I don't
know about how does Angelina Jolie but
we're like super hot or we're like super
beautiful
so it does happen but
it's hard it doesn't happen that often
so I think that if you put it in a movie
like people aren't gonna buy it you know
what I'm saying you have to have
somebody that looks more
like a regular person
and in a way I kind of feel like I
always feel like the British film
industry was like way ahead of us on
this one because they do seem to have a
lot more movies and TV shows that just
have regular ass looking people in them
and sometimes they're good looking and
sometimes they're just kind of average
looking or sometimes they're
not that good looking but it's just kind
of it's more realistic to me
I don't need to have like super hot like
but to me it's like if you have super
hot looking people like in a movie it
almost kind of like takes you out of it
because you're like you don't buy it you
know what I mean she's like this isn't a
regular person especially if it's like
Zack said if it's just somebody that's
doing like regular [__] it's like we're
making a movie about somebody
that lives in a trailer park and you
know does this and that like works at
Dollar General or whatever and then they
look like some [__] hot like No One's
Gonna buy that you know what I mean you
have to they don't have to be ugly they
can be pretty but you can't they can't
be like Hollywood pretty you know what I
mean because No One's Gonna [__] buy
that [__] because like you look like
that why the [__] do you you wouldn't
work there if you look like that come on
but yeah so I'm just saying but yeah so
I so I think that's kind of the problem
uh Victor says all the hot Tick Tock
dudes I follow from California
uh yeah I believe it Zach says or Fatal
Attraction Michael Douglas and Glenn
Close were good looking back in the day
but they still look like the average
person I think it makes it more
immersive yeah it does make it more
believable like I said the whole thing
about a movie is that you have to be
able to immerse yourself in the fiction
right so it's just like if there's
something if there's an element that's
distracting
um even if it's this this person is too
good looking for the role that you're
expecting me to believe that they're
playing then that's an issue
Glenn Close is a beautiful woman but not
she's not like what they would call a
traditionally beautiful woman you know
what I mean so I think it was good that
they got her she's less beautiful and
like more sexy I guess because there's a
difference between those two things
incidentally my favorite Glenn Close
role is in Dangerous Liaisons which if
you have not seen that adaptation
they've made it a couple of times and I
read the novel as well
um I actually
one of the things I I was trying to like
impress myself because I took French in
high school
and I tried to read it in the original
French
when I was in high school
um I kind of understood about a third of
it I think but
um but then I read it in English
translation it is it is a good play
but they made it a couple of times but
the one with John Malkovich Michelle
Pfeiffer and Glenn Close is still my
favorite one and I've seen that movie
like a million times and I think that is
probably my favorite Glenn Close role
and probably my favorite Glenn or my
favorite um John Malkovich role as well
I just love that [__] movie that's
one of my favorite [__] movies ever
but that's the thing like Glenn Close in
that movie you could buy like she's not
beautiful beautiful but you could
believe that she was like sexy enough to
manipulate like all these people around
like she was very imperious you know
what I'm saying so it's just kind of
like it's we've talked about this before
sexy and beautiful are two different
things that's two different things yeah
yogurt looks good
enough the yoga is made a half gallon of
yogurt in the instant box
let's see what it tastes like I mean
hopefully it'll be ready tomorrow we'll
see a lot cheaper than buying it yeah
just make it I think I still got some in
the fridge I get that Chobani kind of
that has like the mix-ins I have key
lime I think yeah
but yeah they're talking about
um I was laughing about Zach saying
about a movie about a McDonald's cashier
and they look like Angelina Julie
yeah
although no hey man [__] I've been at
McDonald's flicking up around Sanford
and everything not Stanford though
where's Altamont where you slip and the
girls were cute in there well like I was
saying a lot of money like I said I
would I would you know there are like a
lot of because I've been to fast food
restaurants or and there were like
really yeah like good looking people
working there yeah but if you put it in
a movie people wouldn't necessarily they
don't believe it they wouldn't buy it so
that's the thing you're trying to get
people to like buy into the fiction but
then he was um talking about Glenn Close
that I was talking about talking about
um Fatal Attraction and then I was
talking about Dangerous Liaisons which
is another movie we have not
reviewed even though that's one of my
favorite movies I've seen it a couple
times I saw it in the Army a couple
times when I was up in Egypt I love that
[__] movie we had the VHS we would
watch it I told him I said I tried to
like be cool and like I tried to I tried
to read it in high school because I took
French and I tried to read it in the
original French yeah
um which was only partially successful
my friend Eric the guy that moved into
the bad house with me afterwards he
[__] liked that movie and every time
he'd [__] get into a Jammy just was
good it's beyond my control
and uh whenever he started saying it was
beyond everything this means he was
gonna do some [__] up [__] oh my God I
love it my control is
and I know exactly what he's talking
about yeah yeah I've seen that movie so
many times I know exactly what he's
talking about yeah like but oh we should
review that okay oh I kind of want to
watch it again now
I love that [__] Movie that that
movie like most of my favorite favorite
movies are horror movies but non horror
movies that are my favorite dangerous
liaison's probably my favorite Amadeus
is probably one of my other favorites I
[__] love Amadeus we grew up watching
that [__] oh my God that was the first
Blu-ray I think I ever bought no the
first DVD I ever bought yeah when I
bought a DVD player the first DVD I
bought was Amadeus it was a funny I
liked it the second one was Clockwork
it's still a good movie to watch it but
I didn't realize as a kid
I just liked it and then as an adult I
went back and watched him realized how
annoying [__] Mozart is in that
[__] well yeah you up the [__]
wall he's Twisted but he was supposed to
be like that but yeah well the whole
thing about it and like I said it's not
based on reality reality like some of it
is
um it's based on a play
and it was kind of like the play was
sort of like
um you know
kind of hyping up the Rivalry between
salieri and Mozart which
wasn't really the case I mean I've read
so like I'm fascinated by Mozart so I've
read like a lot of um biographies of him
and a lot of that stuff not so much like
them were they they were mostly friends
and they collaborated on a lot of stuff
uh there's absolutely no evidence that
salieri like killed him or anything like
that but that a lot of people have that
perception now because of that play and
then that movie that they made about it
but it's still like a great [__]
movie milosh Foreman he was the one that
directed it did he get the Oscar for
that he got nominated for sure 84 I
think that came out on cable for years
straight God damn it I love that movie
it's like and that's another movie that
I never ever get sick of
I've probably seen that movie a hundred
times I like The Shining yeah it's just
one of those movies like I said The
Shining or the thing Amadeus Dangerous
Liaisons if you ask me right now like
you want to watch it even though I've
seen it 100 times yeah [__] yeah I'll
watch it again
I don't know why it's just they're very
comforting Clockwork Orange is another
one like that like I've also seen that
about a hundred times it is 11. okay I'm
gonna shut this [__] down I guess we
should yeah we gotta [__] even though
I'm having it yeah we should we should
probably have some more peanut butter
cookies too yeah
because it's Friday night I don't have
to get up tomorrow okay so yeah we'll
sleep in
yeah Victor said I remember renting a
Blu-ray movie at Blockbuster and getting
mad because it wouldn't play on my DVD
player oh
yeah yeah I didn't buy a DVD player
until later
um because you know I didn't have the
money to be up on the latest technology
or whatever but when I finally got a DVD
player Amadeus was the first movie that
I bought
um I thought what's his face who played
Mozart was adorable as [__] Tom Hulse
um he was in some other [__] too he was
in a movie called slam dance which was
actually quite good if I remember I
haven't seen it in a while
um but if you want to watch that uh I
really liked it
I mean I think I he was in a lot of
other [__] too but I kind of feel like
that role sort of defined him but like I
said he was supposed to be annoying he
was supposed to be annoying because the
whole point of the movie was that you
were seeing things from salieri's point
of view it was salieri's flashback he
was talking about it so you're going to
see Mozart the way he saw him
you know so that's kind of how I took it
but it's a great [__] movie I love
that [__] movie so much now like I
said now I want to watch that again too
boom we'll see I think I have it
someplace
I don't know all right so we're gonna
wrap it up because we've been on here a
very long time
but that's okay all right so we're gonna
be back on Sunday I don't know what
movie we're gonna be talking about yet
because we haven't watched one so we'll
think of something
maybe one of y'all's suggestions we'll
look into it or maybe one of the movies
we were just talking about we'll look
into that too we'll see how that goes
it'll be a surprise for you guys and for
us so hopefully you guys enjoyed this
rambling discussion this evening have a
good rest of your Friday night have a
good day tomorrow we'll see you guys
again on Sunday for the movie review
good Nate